THE SENATE
HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE WILL
COME TO ORDER. GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVER NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE IN THE CAPITAL WITH SOME
OF OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. THIS
MORNING WE HAVE SENATOR JACKSON
WHO IS ATTENDING REMOTELY
SENATOR JACKSON IF YOU HAVE
STAFF PERSON WITH YOU CAN YOU
PLEASE IDENTIFY THE STAFF
PERSON AT THIS MOMENT.
CERTAINLY GOOD MORNING- MY
STAFF PERSON TODAY IS PATRICIA
HEROES. THANK YOU SENATOR
JACKSON. CENTERS AS A REMINDER
PLEASE MEET YOUR PHONES OR
COMPUTERS THIS WILL GREATLY AID
IN ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK PASSED THAT EVERY TIME
YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZE THAT
YOU RAISED YOUR HAND FEATURE IN
THE PROGRAM EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO AND MUTE.
PLEASE THE ME BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAK I T. WILL YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN ARE DONE ONCE
RECOGNIZE AS BEING PLEASED YOUR
NAME AND THE BAY NUMBER TO
WHICH YOU ARE REFERRING. TO A
LOT ABOUT ACCESS ADMITTED MY OF
THE TO Y. OR TWO. ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT SOCIAL TO RICK ARE. I
WILL BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
OF IS FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE. IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. FOUR NINE FIVE THREE
EIGHT SIX EIGHT. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO. THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE AND OR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY MARK
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE ZERO FOR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION. PRESAS
ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER. THIS
CAN BE SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL
WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU'LL BE%
A MUTED AND YOU'RE NOW READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID A
PACIFIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET
THE DEVICE FOR WATCHING. AND
HEARING A PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINED HERE PROCESS AND
CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS AND THAT'S
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LACK TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS FOR
JUSTIN TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE
TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE
BE RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO
ALL INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. WE HAVE THIRTEEN BILLS.
TODAY'S AGENDA. LET'S START
WITH ESTABLISHING A QUORUM I'D
LIKE TO REMIND MEMBERS TO TURN
ON THEIR MICROPHONES AND SPEAK
INTO THEIR MICROPHONES
THROUGHOUT THE MEET THROUGHOUT
THE HEARING. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. PORTATO BUT.
FIVE PRESENT FURTADO PRESENT
JONES JONES PRESENT BELL.
JACKSON ACTION PRESENT. JACKSON
PRESENTS PAN HERE. CAN PRESENTS
MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ PRESENTS
WINNER. WE HAVE A QUORUM. A
QUORUM HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED.
AND AT THIS MOMENT WE WILL
BEGIN WITH. FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE. WE HAVE THE AUTHOR OF
THE BILL HERE TODAY TO PRESENT
ON AB EIGHTEEN FORTY FIVE.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS- I
WOULD LIKE TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
PROPOSED TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS
AND THANKING THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR THOROUGH
EVALUATION OF THIS LARGEST
CHEN. AB EIGHTEEN FORTY FIVE
ESTABLISHES THE OFFICE TO END
HOMELESSNESS WHICH WILL BE
HOUSED IN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
THE OFFICE WILL BE OVERSEEN BY
A NEW SECRETARY ON HOMELESSNESS
THIS NEW SECRETARY WILL BE IN
CHARGE OF OVER OVERSEEING ALL
STATE HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS.
THAT WOULD CONTINUE TO BE
MANAGED BY EXISTING ENTITIES.
IN ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS I
TOOK AMENDMENTS THAT REMOVED
ANY COST PRESSURES ASSOCIATED
WITH THE MEASURE BY
TRANSFERRING EXISTING STAFF AND
RESOURCES TO THE OFFICE TO THE
NEW OFFICE TO END HOMELESSNESS-
FOR CONTEXT I SHOULD POINT OUT
THAT WE HAVE ADDED MORE AND
MORE LAYERS OF NEW POLICIES
OVER SEVERAL DECADES. TO COMBAT
THE INCREASING. HOMELESSNESS
EPIDEMIC AT THIS POINT THERE
ARE AT LEAST THIRTEEN DIFFERENT
STATE AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS
ADMINISTERING. OVER THIRTY
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS RELATED TO
HELP ASSESS WELL WELL IN. WE
HAVE CREATED A THAT IS
FRAGMENTED OFTEN WITH
CONFLICTING GOALS THAT PLEASE
REFER IN A- RESPONSE AT THE
STATE LEVEL. THE RECOMMENDATION
HAS WELL DONE. OVER THE- IN
NINETEEN A NINE LITTLE WHO
BURKE. RECOMMEND UNIT ALL HOME.
STATE PROGRAMS INTO ONE ENTITY
GRAMS THEN TOOK IT. OKAY A
THREE DAY THE TECH LATER IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE STATE
AUDITOR REPORTED THE CORE
REASON OUR UNSHELTERED HOMELESS
POPULATION EXCEEDS THAT OF
OTHER STATES IS DUE TO THE FACT
THAT THE OTHER STATES HAVE A
SINGLE ENTITY CHARGED
SPECIFICALLY WITH ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS. THE GOVERNOR'S
OWN TASK FORCE EVEN CALLED FOR
A SINGLE OFFICE ON HOMELESSNESS.
RECENTLY THAT LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE ISSUED A
REPORT HIGHLIGHTING THE VARIOUS
CHALLENGES THAT THE STATE MUST
OVERCOME TO RESOLVE OUR
EXISTING FRAGMENTED RESPONSE TO
THIS GROWING CRISIS. SINCE THE
START OF COPA NINETEEN SEVEN
MILLION INDIVIDUALS HAVE FILED
FOR UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS FOR
THE FIRST TIME BECAUSE OF THESE
JOB LOSSES WE KNOW OUR
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS IS ONLY
GOING TO GET WORSE. THIS
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION
HAVE DEDICATED SUBSTANTIAL
RESOURCES TO COMBAT
HOMELESSNESS WHILE STATE
FUNDING PLAYS A CRITICAL ROLE
FUNDING ALONE WILL NOT SOLVE
SYSTEMIC ISSUES IT'S TIME THAT
WE FINALLY ADDRESS. OUR
STRUCTURAL ISSUES AT THE STATE
LEVEL TO END THIS CRISIS TODAY
FOR TESTIMONY I HAVE SHARON
REPORT DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA
STATE POLICY FOR THE
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING. AND GINNY BELLA- FROM
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST OFFICE
WHO'S HERE TO SPEAK- TO THE
RECENT FINDINGS ON OUR CURRENT
EFFORTSTO COMBAT HOMELESSNESS.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JENNY BELLOW WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
ARE YOU ABLE TO HEAR ME. YES WE
CAN. THANK YOU. WHAT OFFICE NOT
TAKE POSITION THAT BILL ON
BUILD BECAUSE OF THE WORK WE
HAVE DONE RESPONSE THE
HOMELESSNESS IS AND HOW
RECENTLY WE'VE BEEN ASKED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS TO
PROVIDE THEM TECHNICAL WORK
WITH RELATE TO EIGHT EIGHTEEN
FORTY FIVE. I WILL RIGHT ARE
COMMON FROM A READER REPORT
HOME OR WE JUST CRIED THE FRIED
HE AT THE STATE HOME PROGRAMS
AND WE HAVE CHALLENGES. AND
YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD TODAY.
MULTIPLE STATE BARBARA ARE AND-
IN THE ADMINISTRATION PROGRAM
THAT AIM ADDRESS. AND CAL. EVEN
THE DEPART OF HOUSING COMMUNITY.
AT AND THE LOOK AT COURTNEY AND
BY COUNCIL ON THE OTHERS.
ADDITIONALLY THERE ARE SOME
OTHER TO. THAT EITHER
ADMINISTERED STATE THEY DO NOT
PARK. OR HOW MORE ROLE THAN
ADDRESS HOUSE AND HOME AND HOW.
AND INCLUDE SUCH AS THE DEPART
OF SOCIAL. HOW SERVICES.
VETERANS AFFAIRS. THEY CALL AT
THIS. APPROACH DOES CREATE
CHALLENGES WE THINK THAT THE
STATE. FOR EXAMPLE THERE IS
TRACKING ALSO RELATED ACROSS
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND ISN'T
REALLY BECAUSE THERE'S NOTHING
GROUP FOR THAT IN SO IT'S
DIFFICULT TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
SUCH AS HOW MUCH OF THE STATE
SPENDING TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS. A IT'S DIFFICULT
TO HOW MUCH DATA PLANNING ON ON
PURCHASE. APPROACH SO FAR ARE
WE SPEND MORE ON THE PREVENTION
SIDE WE DOING MORE ON THE
INTERVENTION SIDE IN ANSWERING
THAT QUESTION A DIFFICULT
GIVING THIS FRAGMENTED
APPROACH. THERE'S DIFFICULTY
DETERMINING HOW MANY PROGRAMS
WORK COLLABORATE HOW THE
PROGRAM CAN WORK
COLLABORATIVELY EACH AND
AFFECTING THE PROGRAM HOW THEY
COULD BETTER LEVERAGE ONE
ANOTHER AND ENSURE THAT.
THERE'S NO DUPLICATE EFFORTS.
IN ADOPTING HOMELESS. AND
FINALLY. IT'S HARD TO A HOW THE
STATE DOING. THE HOMEWORK ISSUE
ARE WE A COMP BECAUSE OF THE
THAT NATURE. WHICH TO IN OUR
JANUARY RECORD WE THINK THAT
LET. I IT ON. FOR HOMELESSNESS
AND CAL. AND THE BILL A PLAN
THAT ALLOW WITH PRIORITIES AND
THINK THAT YOU CAN. OF THAT
WITHIN. THE DEVELOP. OF A
STRUCTURE THAT REALLY PRO CLEAR
LEADERS. AND GUIDANCE A- THE
THAT ARE SET OUT BY THE LEAD.
AND WITH THAT BAT QUICKER MY OR
WHICH AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS. GOOD MORNING. MY
NAME IS CHERYL WITH A QUOTE FOR
SUPPORT OF. AS MEMBER OF STATE.
ARRAYS OF THE RANGE IN OF ON
LUNCH NOW FROM THANK YOU AT
WELFARE. CHECK IN ON HOW HAS
BEEN THAT CAL RESPONSE JOHN IS
HIGHLY NAY. INSIDE. AND NO
MEANINGFUL COLLABORATION AND
ARE HOMELESS HOUSING AND
SERVICES PROGRAM. WELCOME HOME
OF COORDINATING AND FINANCING
COUNCIL WAS INTENDED TO BREAK
DOWN THESE SILOS IT HAS NO
AUTHORITY OVER OTHER DEPARTMENT
OR AGENCY. TO COMPOUND
DEPARTMENT DOCTORS SET OF STATE
POLICIES AROUND. IN ADDITION TO
THE ANTI OXIDANTS PROBLEM
MENTIONS THIS RECONCILIATION
AND PARKS LOCAL RESPONSE
AGENCIES AND NONPROFITS MUST
ALSO COMPETE RATHER THAN
COOPERATE WITH THEIR
JURISDICTIONAL COUNTERPARTS
RESPONDS THAT MUST APPLY FOR
FUNDING WITH OFTEN CONFLICTING.
AND CONTRADICTORY REQUIREMENTS.
YES REALITY RATHER THAN
ELIMINATE PR. AB EIGHTEEN FORTY
FIVE WOULD REDUCE THIS FOR OUR
CRISPY BY CREATING A SINGLE
AUTHORITY ON HOMELESSNESS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR OUTCOMES AND
SOLVING HOMELESSNESS AND
COORDINATED WAY. WELL THE
NATIONAL REGISTRATION OWNERSHIP
OVER HOMELESSNESS IS
COMMENDABLE EIGHTEEN FORTY FIVE
PROPOSES INSTITUTIONALIZING.
I'M MORE EFFICIENT BEST THING
OF A SINGLE AUTHORITY DIRECTLY
ACCORDING TO THE GOVERNOR WITH
EXTRA CHEESE OVER HOMELESSNESS
AVERAGING AN OFFICE DEDICATED
TO A COORDINATED RESPONSE. AT
THIS TIME OF THE STATE IS
FACING POTENTIAL INCREASES OF
HOMELESSNESS OF BETWEEN THIRTY
THOUSAND AND A HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS ACCORDING TO
SEVERAL- ACADEMICS ALONG WITH
THE BUDGET CRISIS NOW IS THE
TIME TO MAKE A RESPONSE MORE
EFFICIENT. AND MORE EFFECTIVE.
AB EIGHTEEN FORTY FIVE WILL NOT
REQUIRE THE STATE TO ADD STAFF
WORKING TO SOLVE HOMELESSNESS.
OR TO CREATE IN THE REGION.
HELLO STAFF WORKING FOR THE-
HOMELESS CORE AND- COUNCIL TO
AN OFFICE ON HOMELESSNESS
WITHIN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
GIVING OUT STOCK GREATER
AUTHORITY OVER THE DEPARTMENTS
AND AGENCIES IMPACT. THE BILL
REQUIRES KNOWN AS- AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
SAID SAID THE LEGISLATURE'S
RESPONSIBLE FOR ADOPTING A
STATEWIDE PLAN SUGGESTS
HOMELESSNESS AND REMEDY THE
FRAGMENTED APPROACH. THIS BILL
PROVIDES THAT PLAN A PATH
FORWARD WITH CLEAR
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION TO IMPLEMENT. I
URGE. YOUR I'D VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. SWEAT THIS MOMENT WE
WILL NOT OPEN IT UP TO
WITNESSES OR PUBLIC COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN FORTY
FIVE HERE IN BROOME FORTY TWO
ZERO THREE. C. NINE WE WILL.
NOW MOVE ON TO. A PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE TELEPHONE PUBLIC
LINE. WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCING FIRST AS A
REMINDER TO THOSE WERE WAITING
ON THE PHONE PLEASE LIMIT YOUR
TESTIMONY TO NAME AFFILIATION
IN YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL.
MODERATOR PLEASE PUMP
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN FORTY
FIVE AND PROVIDE THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WAITING TO
TESTIFY. RIGHT NOW WE HAVE FIVE
LINES IN Q. PARDON ME SIX LINES
IN Q. OUR FIRST LINE WILL GO TO
LINE TWENTY NINE. GO AHEAD
PLEASE. I AM NOT SURE WITH THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION FOR. IT WILL MOVE
NEXT TO LINE FIFTY NINE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING REBECCA
GONZALEZ NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT WE WILL TO LINE SIXTY GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MARKET CAREER
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT. TEXAS LINE SIXTY TWO.
GOOD MORNING MA'AM CHAIR AND
MEMBER SERVICES ACROSS BUCKLEY
ON BEHALF OF SACRAMENTO MAYOR
DARRELL STEINBERG AND SPORT.
WE'LL GO TO LINE THIRTY THREE.
THE MORNING CARE AND MEMBERS OF
THE FACILITY DOLLARS ON BEHALF
OF LOS ANGELES CITY ON MAYOR
ERIC GARCETTI IN THE CITY OF
SANTA MONICA IN THE PARK. THANK
YOU. TEN NINE FIFTY FOUR.
MORAYSHIRE MEMBERS BECAUSE
MARTIN FROM HOUSING CALIFORNIA
SPONSORING SUPPORT. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER OUTLINES IN Q. THANK
YOU MARK THANK YOU WATER CAN
YOU JUST PUT PLEASE CHECK THE
LINE ONCE AGAIN TO MAKE SURE WE
HAVE HEARD FROM ALL SUPPORT
WITNESSES ON AB EIGHTEEN FORTY
FIVE. THERE ARE ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE DO HAVE ONE OF THE
LINE QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT
PLEASE WHILE WE PROVIDE THIRD
LINE NUMBER.
WATER LEVELS
ONLINE. WE'LL GO TO LINE SIXTY
FIVE GO AHEAD PLEASE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE THIS IS MY
CLIENT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
CHRISTIAN COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTEEN FORTY FIVE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND THIS TIME WE DO
HAVE ONE MORE LINE QUEUING UP
ONE MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE
PROVIDE THE LINE NUMBER.
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN
UP THE LINE. ONE MOMENT PLEASE
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE SIXTY
IS JULIE SNYDER ON BEHALF OF
THE TIME BURKE AND PUT YOU IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN
FORTY FIVE THANK YOU. AND IF
THERE ARE ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE PLEASE TAKE
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU HAVEN'T HEARD
FROM ALL THE SUPPORTERS WILL
NOW POLICY PROCESS IN HERE FROM
ANY OPPOSITION. AND AT THIS
MOMENT ALL OF BY ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO EIGHTEEN FORTY
FIVE IF THERE ARE ANY. SEEN
NONE- AT THIS MOMENT WE WILL
TAKE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHTEEN FORTY
FIVE AND FORTY TWO ZERO THREE.
SCENE NINE WE WILL MOVE ON TO
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA TELECONFERENCE ARVEST AS A
REMINDER TO BILLS FOR WHEN ON
THE PHONE. PLEASE LIMIT YOUR
TESTIMONY TO NAME AFFILIATION
AND YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL.
AND MODERATOR PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHTEEN
FORTY FIVE. AND PROVIDE THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE WAITED
TO TESTIFY. IF THERE ARE ANY
ONE OF THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
HAVE LONG QUEUING UP AT THIS
TIME YOU MAY PROCEED. YEAH.
MODERATE MODERATE CAN YOU
PLEASE CHECK LINE TO ONCE AGAIN
JUST TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE HEARD
FROM ALL THE OPPOSITION
WITNESSES- ON AB EIGHTEEN FORTY
FIVE. CERTAINLY LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN AGAIN IF YOU HAVE AN
OPPOSITION TO PRESENT. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND AGAIN AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE KNOWN QUEUING UP IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MODERATOR.
AT THIS MOMENT WE WILL GO AHEAD
AND MOVED TO ANY COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WE HAVE WILL
START WITH A SENATOR PAN. RIGHT
NOW I JUST WANTED TO SAY I WANT
TO ASK YOU A CENTER- RIVAS FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD FOR
YOUR WORK ON THIS ISSUE IS
CERTAINLY VERY IMPORTANT A
WHICH I TO CONSULT YOUR TIED TO
US. SO THE MY MAP RIGHT WORD
BUT BETTER COORDINATE OUR
EFFORTS HERE AT THE STATE AND
THEN- WOULD LIKE TO MOVE THE
BUILT APPROPRIATE TIME SO
THANKS SO MUCH FOR BRAINS
BEFORE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
CENTER PAN WILL MOVE ON TO
SENATOR JOHNSON AND SENATOR
JACKSON. I THANK YOU CHAIRMAN.
A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS AND MAYBE
SOME COMMENTS- YOU MENTIONED IN
YOUR OPENING THE GOVERNOR- AND-
HAVING THE HOMELESSNESS ARE I
THINK IS WHAT HE CALLED IT. HI
AND I THINK IT WAS IN EITHER
HIS INAUGURAL SPEECH FOR HIS
FIRST DAY IN THE STATE. THERE
WAS A SAY THE STATE SPEECH HAS
FIRST ONE WHEN HE- SAID H WAS
GONNA POINT- SENATOR STEINBERG
AS THE- STATEWIDE. HOMELESSNESS
THESE ARE DO YOU KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED TO THAT AND WHY WE
HAVEN'T SEEN MOVEMENT ON THAT
PLAN THAT THE GOVERNOR LAID OUT
IN HIS SPEECH. WELL THE
GOVERNOR OF APPOINTED I KNOW
SENATOR STEINBERG ON A TASK
FORCE ON HOMELESSNESS A
STATEWIDE TASK FORCE WHICH I
BELIEVE SENATOR- CENTER
STEINBERG. IS CULTURE. OF AND
WE'VE BEEN. WAITING FOR
RECOMMENDATIONS WHICH WE HAVE
RECEIVED FROM THE TASK FORCE
WHICH INCLUDES- WHAT THIS BILL
WOULD DO TO CENTRALIZE OUR
EFFORTS ON HOMELESSNESS OKAY DO
YOU KNOW WHY THE- OKAY
APPRECIATE YOUR CREATIVITY AND
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH HERE BUT I MEAN THIS
IS A FUNCTION OF THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH. WHY DO WHITE IS THE
LEGISLATURE NEED TO HAVE THIS
WHITE IS IN THE GOVERNOR JUST
DO IT. I THINK AS A LEGISLATURE
THIS IS OUR OPPORTUNITY TO
ESTABLISH PRIORITIES ON
HOMELESSNESS REGARDLESS OF WHO
IS IN THE ADMINISTRATION RIGHT
WE'RE FORTUNATE THAT OUR
GOVERNOR HAS ELEVATED THIS
ISSUE- AND YOU KNOW LIKE YOU
MENTIONED. A MADE THIS THE SOLE
TOPIC OF HIS STATE OF THE STATE
ADDRESS THIS YEAR- BUT WE CAN'T
RELY ON THAT WE AS A
LEGISLATURE WE CAN ESTABLISH
THIS OFFICE- TO END
HOMELESSNESS OKAY. THE I'M JUST
GONNA SHARE SOME PERSONAL
DISAPPOINTMENTS WITH THE WITH
THAT. NOT THIS BILL OR WITH-
WHAT'S HAPPENED SO FAR FROM THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH. YEAH MY
OFFICES RESULTS AS SOON AS A
CENTER STEINBERG WAS APPOINTED
AS CO CHAIR CHAIRMAN OR
WHATEVER IT WAS. HOMELESSNESS
IS A BIG DEAL ALL OVER THE
STATE- IN MY DISTRICT I
REPRESENT MOSTLY. A SUBURBAN
AND RURAL AREAS OF SAN DIEGO
COUNTY. THAT HISTORICALLY HAVE
BEEN KIND OF. NOT IMPACTED TO
DRAMATICALLY BY HOMELESSNESS
WE'VE ALWAYS HAD YOU KNOW SOME
ISSUES OF IT BUT NOT BUT NOT A
LOT- BUT SINCE THE PASSAGE OF
AB ONE OH NINE AND PROP 47-57.
WHICH I THINK IS- EXACERBATED
THE PROBLEMS OF HOMELESSNESS
AND ACTUALLY I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT- I. IMPORTANT AT
POLICY IT WANT PROTECT THIS
THIS PROBLEM OF HOMELESSNESS.
THE WE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THERE'S- I THINK STATEWIDE AND
AN NATION WIDE ACCEPTANCE THAT.
HOMELESSNESS IS ACTUALLY BROKEN
UP INTO THREE DIFFERENT- NOT.
ENTIRELY DISTINCT CATEGORIES OF
CITIZENS BUT- THERE'S SOME
COMMONALITY BETWEEN THE
CRIMINAL ELEMENT OF- VAGRANCY
AND TRESPASSING AND DRUG
ADDICTION AS ONE GROUP. ANOTHER
GROUP BEING- YOU KNOW WHATEVER
SCALEOF MENTAL ILLNESS FROM A
MINOR TO SEVERE. THAT'S ANOTHER
GROUP AND IN THE THIRD GROUP AS
WELL I THINK WE CAN PLEDGE A
CALL- TRULY HOMELESS THOSE THAT
ARE DOWN AND OUT ON THEIR
LOCKED IT HAD JOBS. SINGLE MOM
KIDS DADS WITH KIDS- SELVES.
FINANCIAL SETBACK THAT HAS PUT
THEM INTO THIS CATEGORY OF
HOMELESSNESS THAT I BELIEVE THE
STATE AND A LOT OF THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ARE DOING A
REALLY GOOD JOB OF. HELPING
THOSE PEOPLE GET A HAND UP AND
MOVE BACK INTO A PRODUCTIVE
ELEMENT OF SOCIETY. THE
CHALLENGE THAT I HAVE WITH
WHERE OUR STATE IS RIGHT NOW IS
DEALING WITH THE OTHER TWO
CATEGORIES- THE SEVERE THE
MENTALLY ILL AND I KNOW THAT
CENTER BELL HAS BEEN COMMITTED
TO THAT EVER SINCE I SERVING
THEM HERE. IN THE LEGISLATURE
NOT APPLIED THE EFFORT THAT HE
HAS TAKEN. TO DEAL WITH THAT
ISSUE NOT AND HE AND I HAVE
COOPERATED ON ON MANY THINGS TO
DO THAT. THE I THINK. WHERE
WERE FOR LOSING OUR WAY IN
CALIFORNIA'S ON THE CRIMINAL
ELEMENT OF THIS. AND UNTIL WE
ON WIND AB ONE OH NINE. AND
UNDO PARTS OF PROP FORTY SEVEN
AND PROP FIFTY SEVEN WE'RE NOT
GOING TO SOLVE THIS. THAT
ELEMENT OF THE HOMELESSNESS.
AND I EVEN LIKE. ALMOST DON'T
WANT TO CALL IT HOMELESSNESS
BECAUSE THESE PEOPLE ARE MAKING
BAD LIFE CHOICES. BETTER PUT
THEM ON THE STREETS AND SOME OF
THEM WANT TO STAY ON THE
STREETS THEY THEY DON'T WANT
TO. BE PRODUCTIVE MEMBERS OF
SOCIETY SO UNTIL WE- ADDRESS
THAT CRIMINAL ELEMENT I THINK
ALL OF THIS OTHER STUFF THAT
WE'RE DOING. WE'RE JUST. FOR
LACK OF A BETTER TERM BUT IN
THE WINDOW LITTLE BIT AND TILL
WE AS POLICYMAKERS MAKE THE
TOUGH CHOICES. THAT WE'RE GONNA
ADDRESSES CRIMINAL ELEMENT OF
THE VACANCY IN THE TRUST
PASSING AND THE LIVING ON THE
STREETS- I DON'T KNOW THAT. IS
THAT YOUR IDEA I HAD ABOUT THE
BILL PACKAGE AT THE BEGINNING
OF THE YEAR WITH FIVE BILLS.
THAT ADDRESS SOME OF THIS SOME
OF THE THINGS WE'RE GONNA BE
VOTING ON TODAY. I WAS GONNA.
THE TACKLE AND THEN WE AS WE
ASKED TO. PULL BACK SOME OF OUR
BILLS ARE THOSE THE ONES THAT I
PULLED BACK I KEPT ONE OF THEM
GO ON SO. I ACTUALLY WAS GOING
TO VOTE NO ON THIS TODAY BUT.
HE TESTIMONY. AND YOU GET SOME
SUPPORT. OF WHO I. APPRECIATE
THEIR OPINION. SOME A LAYOFF
TODAY ON THIS- AND I'VE I'M
SORRY BATMAN CHARM I'M PROBABLY
MORE. BLOVIATING THAN I AM.
ASKING A QUESTION IF YOU LIKE
TO ADDRESSING THOSE ISSUES I'M
I'M HAPPY TO HEAR YOUR RESPONSE
TO ANY OF THAT. THANK YOU
SENATOR. YOU KNOW I AGREE WITH
YOU YOU KNOW THIS IS NOT JUST
AN URBAN OR RURAL ISSUE YOU
KNOW I'M FROM LOS ANGELES YOUR
YOU YOU MENTIONED YOU HAVE
RURAL AND SUBURBAN. AREAS IN
YOUR DISTRICT AND WERE ALL
EQUALLY AFFECTED- AND I THINK
IT'S TIME THAT OUR STATE- START
BY CREATING A GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURE. WILL BETTER ADDRESS
LISTS- AND I THINK THAT IS A
START- AND BY STREAMLINING- WE
AND- BRINGING THE RESOURCES
EXISTING RESOURCES THAT WE
ALREADY HAVE. AN ELEVATING THIS
ISSUE WE WILL ABLE TO. WE WOULD
BE ABLE TO WORK THANK YOU
TOWARDS IRAQ I THINK IS ONE OF
THE CLEAR MY FRUSTRATION IS NOT
WITH HIS BILL OR OR DO YOU AS
AN AUTHOR OBVIOUSLY. MY
FRUSTRATION REALLY IS WHAT THE
GOVERNOR. MADE A BUNCH OF
PROMISES BOTH IN HIS PAIN AND
THEN HE EXPECTED THEM IN THE
STATE. STATE YES. AND WE- IN
THIS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO SENATOR
JACKSON AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATE JACKSON HERE I
WASN'T REALLY PLANNING TO DO A-
DEFENSE OF THE GOVERNOR BUT I
WOULD LIKE TO REMIND MY GOOD
CALLING FROM LOS ANGELES. IN
THE TIME OF. STATE OF THE STATE
SPEECH AND TODAY WE'VE HAD
SOMETHING CALLED COVERT
NINETEEN IF WE WANT TO PUT
BLAME ON ANYONE FOR THAT I
THINK WE NEED TO LOOK AT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN THE LACK
OF LEADERSHIP THERE SO THIS
DOESN'T HAVE ANYTHING TO DO
WITH THE GOVERNOR- AT THIS
MOMENT THIS HAS TO DO WITH THE
SOCIETAL PROBLEM IT'S EXISTED
FOR DECADES AND CALIFORNIA IS
THE HOME TO MORE HOMELESS
PEOPLE. IN MEASURE BECAUSE YOU
HAVE A CHOICE BETWEEN BEING
HOMELESS IN DECEMBER IN YOUR
CAR HOMELESS IN DECEMBER IN
CALIFORNIA- YOU WILL TO
CALIFORNIA SO THAT IS PART OF
THE PROBLEM IS THE MAIN. YOU
CAN WE- I THINK IT WAS GOOD AT
THE- HE OPENED UP DORS TO OUR-
AND MANY INSTITUTIONS PROMISING
THAT WE WOULD END UP WITH A
COMMUNITY BASED CARE FOR THOSE
PEOPLE WHO SUFFER MENTAL
ILLNESS AND NEVER FUNDED IT. SO
THAT'S OUR IF WE START LOOKING
AT WHERE THE PROBLEM LIES OR
WHERE IT STARTED- THAT BEING
SAID WE HAVE PEOPLE WITH
TERRIBLE SUBSTANCE ABUSE ISSUES
ARE THAT WE HAPPEN TO DRESSED
IN THE WHAT WE DO WITH THEM.
PRIMARILY AS WE PUT THEM IN
JAIL THAT DOESN'T SOLVE THE
THEIR SUBSTANCE ABUSE PROBLEMS
THEN THEY COME BACK OUT ON THE
STREETS THEY HAVE NOWHERE TO GO
THEY RE OFFEND IF YOU WILL WITH
VAGRANCY OR WHAT HAPPENED AND
IN THE BACK. I IN IN
INCARCERATION COSTING THE STATE
ENORMOUS AMOUNTS OF MONEY- THE
SO CALLED CRIMINAL ELEMENT I
WOULD SUGGEST THOUGH THE
RESULTS ARE RESOLUTE AND IS TO.
A DAM OPPOSITION FORTY SEVEN
AND OTHERS THAT ARE TRYING TO
REFORM THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM BUT TO SUPPORT THEM
BECAUSE THE GOAL OF THOSE
PROGRAMS IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE DON'T RESIDENT RIGHT
THAT THEY HAVE A PLACE TO LIVE
A JOB TO GO TO ANALYZE TO HALF.
SO I WASN'T REALLY PLANNING ON
DOING THAT IN THE DRESSING THIS
BILL BUT SINCE TO BEG THE
QUESTION ARE I THINK THAT WE
REALLY HAVE TO BE HONEST AND
ACCURATE ABOUT WHAT THE
PROBLEMS ARE SO I WANT TO
SUPPORT THIS AND I WANT TO
THANK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER. FOR
BRINGING IT BECAUSE ALMOST HAS
BEEN A PROBLEM IN CALIFORNIA
FOR DECADES WHEN I FIRST
STARTED MY LEGAL CAREER RIGHT
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY- CAR WAS
PROBLEM CREATED ENORMOUS IMPACT
ON OUR COURT SYSTEM OUR CREW
JOHN JUST- IN THE. THOSE WHO
NEED HELP. AND WE NEED TO DO
BETTER AND I THINK THAT
CREATING THIS FOCUS AND HAVING
A SYSTEM. WHERE WE SET UP A-
BASED YOU KNOW HOMELESSNESS
BASED A SERIES OF EFFORTS AND
PROGRAMS FROM HOME FROM HOUSING
TO MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES AND I
KNOW MY GOOD COLLEAGUE SENATOR
BELT COULD PROBABLY TALK ABOUT
THIS ISSUE FOR HOURS BECAUSE OF
HIS COMMITMENT. TO IMPROVING
THE MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAMS THAT
WE HAVE IN THE STATE- I THINK
THIS IS A REALLY EXCELLENT IDEA
TO DEMONSTRATE THE COMMITMENT
THAT WE HAVE AS A STATE AND AS
A LEGISLATURE- TO DEALING WITH
THIS ISSUE AND I HAVE EVERY
CONFIDENCE THAT. THE GOVERNOR
DOES SHARE THIS- PERSPECTIVE
AND- I SUSPECT WILL- MAKE
APPOINTMENTS TO WITH THAT
REFLECT THAT COMMITTEE. AND THE
COMMITMENT TO EXCELLENCE THAT
YOU HOPE. OKAY AND WE WILL BE
TO PURSUE HEARING SO WITH THE I
KNOW THAT SENATOR BEAT ME TO
MOVING THE BUT I'M- I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING.
THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SAYS CENTER
WINNER. THANK YOU AYE MANAGER
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD I'VE
ALWAYS THOUGHT THIS WAS A VERY
GOOD. AND IMPORTANT BILL- BUT
ACTUALLY- HAS BECOME MUCH MORE
RELEVANT AND- YOU KNOW I WANT
TO SAY AND I DON'T THINK THAT
THIS I DON'T THINK THERE'S BEEN
A NOT URGENT ENOUGH OF A SENSE
OF URGENCY. IN THIS BUILDING-
ABOUT THE WAVE OF HOMELESSNESS
THAT IS GOING TO HIT US AS WE
SEE MASSIVE ACTIONS. HAPPENING
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE
ARE. IN A PLACE RIGHT NOW.
WHERE WE HAVE A HUMAN 40% OF
CALIFORNIANS ARE RENTERS LIKE
SIXTEEN MILLION PEOPLE. AND
THEY ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
LOWER INCOME OR EVEN VERY LOW
INCOME. THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC WERE OFTEN
HANGING ON. BY THEIR
FINGERNAILS. AND NOW THEY HAVE
SO MANY OF THEM HAVE LOST THEIR
JOBS. THEY ARE IN DIRE STRAITS
AND NOW BECAUSE OF INACTION
FIVE AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL THEIR
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS ARE
TANKING. THAT IS IF THEY'VE
BEEN ABLE TO GET UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS BECAUSE OF THE
MELTDOWN- ET DE. AND SO WE FACE
THE VERY REAL PROSPECT THAT IN
THE COMING MONTHS I THINK AT
THE BEGINNING BECAUSE OF MAYBE
MINIMAL SAVINGS THAT PEOPLE
OUTSIDE OR- BECAUSE THEY GOT
THE EXTRA SIX HUNDRED
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS. OR
RECALLS THAT A LANDLORD WHO IS
UNDERSTANDING AT LEAST FOR A
LITTLE WHILE. YOU KNOW THERE
WAS A IS NARRATIVE UNKNOWNS WE
PEOPLE AREN'T DEFAULTING ON THE
RENT AND LARGE NUMBERS. OF THAT
IS CHANGING DRAMATICALLY I'M
NOT CHANGED WORK CELERY IN THE
COMING MONTHS AND WE FACE THE
VERY REAL PROSPECT OF A HUGE
NUMBER. OF LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIA. BECOMING HOMELESS
NOW AND IN THE COMING MONTHS.
AND SO I HAVE A QUESTION FOR
THE L. A. O. BASED ON ITS
REPORT- IN TERMS OF. IN
PARTICULAR. NOT JUST WHAT WE'RE
SEEING IN HOMELESSNESS BUT WHAT
WE CAN ANTICIPATE A SPIKE IN
HOMELESSNESS. OF OUR WORKING
POOR. IN THE COMING MONTHS. IS
THE STRUCTURE. THAT EXECUTIVE
BRANCH HAS A NET HAS IN PLACE
NOW. ADEQUATE TO THE TASK. TO
DEAL WITH A POTENTIAL
SIGNIFICANT. SPIKE IN
HOMELESSNESS BECAUSE OF THIS
BILL IS ABOUT. IT'S ABOUT A
RESTRUCTURING TO BETTER BE
BETTER EQUIPPED TO CONFRONT
THIS CRISIS. BUT MY QUESTION TO
THE L. L. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION THIS IS JENNY BALLOT
AGAIN WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. YEAH OUR
RECORDS IDENTIFIED THE NEED FOR
IMPROVED GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE
EVEN PRIOR TO THE CURRENT COLD
AT NINETEEN- STATE OF EMERGENCY
AND SO I THINK THAT BECAUSE OF
THE ISSUES THAT YOU RAIN. TODAY
BOTH ISSUES ARE HEIGHTENED AND
IF ANYTHING THE CHALLENGES FOR
THIRD RESULTING FROM COLBERT
NINETEEN MAKE THE NEED FOR
IMPROVED GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE.
EVEN MORE APPARENTLY SOMETHING
THAT THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD BE
CONSIDERING. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WE HAVE ONE MORE QUESTION
FROM CENTRE BELL. RESERVE THIS
IS A VERY IMPORTANT- DIRECTION
I THINK WE NEED TO TAKE. YES OF
COURSE MY FAMILY WE WERE
HOMELESS WE HAD A FIRE. HOUSE
BURNED DOWN. THE TWELVE OF US
SO. COACH SIR FOR OVER A YEAR
FINDING PLACES TO LIVE FROM
VARIOUS PEOPLE- AT THE TIME WE
DID HAVE. DEPRESSION IT WAS
TOUGH. I REMEMBER THE FAMILY
REALLY- REACHED OUT TO. OUR
SPIRITUALITY AND OUR OUR CHURCH
TO HELP US. SURVIVE THE CRISIS
OUR FAMILY WAS AND- WE. WE
REQUIRE THE OLDER CHILDREN TO
GO TO WORK AND I WAS ONE OF THE
OLDER CHILDREN SO I WANT TO
WORK I FIND OUT THAT THERE WAS
RULES ABOUT MY AGE. SO I GUESS
SORRY FUDGE MY AGE ON SOME OF
THE APPLICATIONS STATING I WAS
A LITTLE OLDER THAN I WAS I WAS
FOURTEEN AT THE TIME SO I
FUDGED A LITTLE BIT RIGHT NOW I
THINK THERE'S A STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS FOR THAT BUT. YOU
KNOW SO I GUESS THAT MAKES ME A
CRIMINAL. IT'S LIKE UP SO
THERE'S. MY OBSERVATION AS-
YEAH YOU DO THINGS WHEN YOU'RE
HOMELESS BUT YOU'RE NOT GONNA
BE HOMELESS FOREVER OKAY SO YOU
SHOULD HAVE LABELS ON PEOPLE.
OKAY I THINK PEOPLE RECOVER
FROM HOMELESSNESS HOPEFULLY
MOST OF THEM DO. AND REACH UP
AND NOT RECOVER. WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE A SITUATION WHERE. WE MAY
FACED AS A PROBABLY WILL FACES-
CENTER WINNER WAS POINTING OUT.
A GREAT INCREASE IN
HOMELESSNESS. BUT WE HAVE TO WE
HAVE TO TAKE THE POSITIVE
VIEWPOINT THE. THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE HOMELESS THAT WILL BECOME
HOMELESS OR PEOPLE THAT WE CAN
HELP WE CAN ASSUME THIS WEEKEND.
DEVELOP STRATEGIES THE BILL
POINTS OUT AND THAT AND I THINK
ANOTHER THING WE AGREE THE
REVOLVES ALL THE DIFFERENT
THINGS HEALTH CARE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE. ALL THE ELEMENTS. AND
IT ALSO MEANS THAT THEY SHOULD
WORK TOGETHER. AS A TEAM. THAT
THE BILL REQUIRES GENERAL CROSS
SYSTEM GENERAL CROSS SYSTEM SO
SORRY TAKEN POINTING OUT SOME
OF THE ASSETS THAT I SEE IN THE
BILL. THE MENTAL HEALTH THING.
ONLY 14% OF PEOPLE GET ADEQUATE
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT THAT'S
GOING TO THAT IS A PROBLEM TO
HAVE DENTURES 0% GET ADEQUATE
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT IF THEY
BECOME HOMELESS. SO I CHECKED.
I THINK THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT BILL IN TERMS OF
GETTING THE GOVERNOR PUTTING IT
IN THE GOVERNOR OFFICE AS
OPPOSED TO LETTING EACH
DEPARTMENT OR EACH AGENCY DO
WITH ALMOST A SEPARATELY I
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT
WE NOT. HAVE SERVE A KEYSTONE
COPS APPROACH TO HOMELESSNESS
THAT WE HAVE A COORDINATED
EFFICIENT. APPROACH AND NOT
WASTE MONEY CHASING RAINBOWS
ARECHOOSING DIFFERENT
SOLUTIONS IN EACH EACH LITTLE
BOX THAT WE PUT OURSELVES AND
THEN THE DEPARTMENTS AND
GOVERNMENT BUREAUCRACIES SO HI
I THINK THIS IS A- I. THINK
THAT WE SHOULD BE DOING MORE OF
CROSS SYSTEMS KIND OF ISSUES
THAT COVER MOST APART DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS AND- I APPRECIATE
THE BILL I THOUGHT IT WAS A
WISE BOTH. OF THE DISPLAYED
SOME WISDOM. THAT WE NEED TO
HAVE IN THE LIGHT OF THE CRISIS
THERE WERE AND SO- JUICE HERE
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
SENATOR PAN THANK YOU MEASURE
AND APPRECIATE YOUR INDULGENCE
I DECIDE ANOTHER REFERENCE WAS
MADE TO MENTAL HEALTH SUBSTANCE
USE AND HOMELESSNESS I JUST DO
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT- WILL
CERTAINLY MENTAL HEALTH. ISSUES
COULD EXXON OR VULNERABLE TO
BECOMING HOMELESS IT'S USUALLY
THE OTHER WAY AROUND IT'S WHAT
HAPPENS IS THAT THROUGH
ECONOMIC MEANS OR OTHER WAYS
PEOPLE BECOME HOMELESS AND THEN
THERE MENTAL. SUBSTANCE USE
INCREASES BECAUSE YOU LOSE THE
SOCIAL SUPPORT AND VARIOUS
OTHER FACTORS WILL GO INTO
RIGHT NOW SO- I KNOW THAT
OFTENTIMES PEOPLE TALK ABOUT
WELL YOU KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES WHO ARE
HOMELESS. JUST KEEP IN MIND
THAT THERE HOMELESSNESS IS BY
WHAT'S EXACERBATING OR MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES MENTAL HEALTH
ITSELF DOESN'T CAUSE
HOMELESSNESS. NECESSARILY AND-
ATTACK THAT'S WHY HOUSING FIRST
IS A VERY IMPORTANT AND
DIVERGENCE BASED APPROACH TO
ADDRESSING THESE SSUES AS WELL
BECAUSE YOU CAN ACTUALLY GET
SOMEONE INTO A HOME- INTO A
PLACE THEN YOU CAN ACTUALLY
START TACKLING THESE ISSUES I
THINK A CENTER BILL SAID.
PROBABLY YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE
HOMELESS OR UNLIKELY TO BE
GETTING THE TREATMENT THEY NEED
BUT ALSO POINT OUT THAT BEING
HOMELESS ITSELF IS. A RISK
FACTOR FOR EXACERBATIONS OF
THOSE CONDITIONS SO WITH THAT I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY JUST
TO MENTION THANK YOU. SENATOR
MELINDA. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
ASSEMBLY WOMAN RIVAS THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
AND I CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO I'M AND I
COMMEND THAT AND I'D AND I'D-
RESPECT THE OPINION COMING FROM
MY COLLEAGUES HERE ON THE
COMMITTEE- AND IT'S YOU KNOW
IT'S IT IT'S AN ISSUE THAT
DESERES TO BE DEALT WITH
COMPASSIONATELY I'M REGARDLESS
OF WHY YOU THINK A PERSON IS
HOMELESS- IT IT IS A
COMPASSIONATE ISSUE- BUT MY
ISSUE. WITH THE BILL IS THAT. I
DON'T KNOW THAT WE NEED TO
CREATE ANOTHER- CIRCLE OF
BUREAUCRACY TO DEAL WITH THE
ISSUE I THINK THERE ARE A LOT
OF OTHER THINGS THAT WE CAN DO
I UNDERSTAND WHERE YOU'RE
COMING FROM THAT YOU FEEL LIKE
SOME SORT OF CENTRALIZED
OVERSIGHT MAKES MORE SENSE BUT-
HONESTLY I FEEL AS THOUGH IT
NEEDS TO BE. ANY TO CONTINUE
PERHAPS MORE SAID LOCAL LEVEL
RATHER THAN FROM THE TOP DOWN-
BECAUSE IT IS DIFFICULT FOR.
THOSE OF US APPEARING
SACRAMENTO TO KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT'S GOING ON ON THE GROUND
IN SOME OF THESE COUNTIES- I
HAD. A COMMUNICATION WITH-
SOMEONE IN SAN FRANCISCO
ACTUALLY THIS WEEKEND WHO IS
HOMELESS AND SHE WAS VERY
FRUSTRATED THAT POLITICIANS
KEEP YOU KNOW THAT WE KEEP
TRYING TO FIX THE PROBLEM. I
AND- THE HER FEELING WAS THE
PROBLEM IS BECAUSE LIVING IS
TOO HIGH WE'RE NOT DOING ENOUGH
TO LOWER THE COST OF LIVING AND
THAT WE ARE ACTUALLY- MAKING IT
WORSE. BY GETTING MORE INVOLVED
AT THE TOP. IN THIS IS SOMEONE
WHO'S LIVING IT YOU KNOW SHE'S
WORKING BY. HE JUST CAN'T
AFFORD THE COST OF LIVING HERE
SO UNFORTUNATELY THOUGH I'D I
KNOW WHERE YOUR HEART IS ON
THIS BILL AND I THANK YOU FOR
THAT I'M NOT. GOING TO BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT THE BILL SIMPLY
BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE. IT NEEDS
TO GO LOWER RATHER THAN GO
HIGHER BUT I DO THINK THAT WE
ALL ARE ON THE SAME PAGE WITH
RESPECT TO. GETTING SOME THINGS
DONE THAT ACTUALLY ALLEVIATE
THIS PROBLEM BECAUSE AS SOME OF
MY COLLEAGUES MENTIONED THIS
HOMELESSNESS ISSUE HAS ONLY
GOTTEN WORSE IN CALIFORNIA OVER
MANY MANY YEARS. AND NO MATTER
WHAT POLITICIANS. TRY TO DO IT
DOESN'T APPEAR TO BE GETTING
ANY BETTER IN FACT IT ACTUALLY
SEEMS TO BE GETTING WORSE SO I
AM LESS INCLINED. TO SUPPORT A
GROUP THAT IS HEADED BY. PEOPLE
FRANKLY WHO WERE FRIENDS TO THE
CITIES I HAVE SOME OF THE WORST
HOMELESSNESS IN THE STATE- TO.
ME TO PUT MY SUPPORT. BEHIND
THE BUT BUT AGAIN THANK YOU AYE
I KNOW YOUR HEART IS ON THIS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ARE AT
THIS MOMENT AUTHORED WOULD YOU
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. SURE
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- THROUGH THIS
DISCUSSION I THINK IT SHOWS HOW
IMPORTANT THIS ISSUE IS TO ALL
OF US- REAP WHAT REGARDLESS OF
WHERE WE'RE- THIS IS. A DISH.
ALL TO BE ALL THE TO SEE I
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS DONE SO FAR TO
ELEVATE HOMELESSNESS- AS
SENATOR JACKSON MENTIONED IT'S
ONLY BEEN A FEW MONTHS- SINCE
THE STATE OF THE STATE WE ARE
STILL IN THIS YEAR AND THIS IS
STILL AN OPPORTUNITY- TO START.
BOND OR CONTINUE THE WORK ON
HOMELESSNESS- BY BY EIGHT
CREATING THIS THIS GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURE THAT'S DESIGNED TO BE
MORE EFFECTIVE- AND TO
STREAMLINE OUR EXISTING
PROGRAMS- YOU KNOW AT. LEADERS
I THINK WE NEED TO CONSIDER THE
BENEFITS OF CREATING THIS.
LASTING STRUCTURAL CHANGE TO.
THE CENTRALIZED OFFICE ON
HOMELESSNESS IS NOT SOMETHING.
THAT CAN BE DONE VIA EXECUTIVE
ORDER THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
THE LEGISLATURE COULD PUT INTO
STATUTE. AND CREATE THIS OFFICE
SO IT CONTINUES TO EXIST.
BEYOND THIS. ADMINISTRATION OF.
OUR FOCUS ON HOMELESSNESS NOT
BE SUBJECT TO THE WHIMS OF AN
ADMINISTRATION IT SHOULD BE
SOMETHING THAT THE LEGISLATURE.
OF YOU KNOW PRIORITIZES AND
CONTINUES TO WORK ON- BEYOND
THE ADMINISTRATION. LIKE THIS
IS JUST THIS ISSUE OF COURSE
LIKE YOU HAVE MENTIONED IS NOT
JUST A STATE LEVEL ISSUE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS- HAVE DONE A LOT OF
WORK ALREADY AND I THINK THAT
BY ESTABLISHING THIS OFFICE WE
WILL BE ABLE TO PROVIDE MORE
SUPPORT. TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS-
AND NOT LESS WE'RE NOT TAKING
STAFF FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
PUTTING IT INTO A STATE OFFICE
WE ARE. CENTRALIZING OUR
CURRENT STRUCTURE TO PROVIDE
MORE SUPPORT TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS SO THAT THEY CAN
CONTINUE THE WORK THAT THEY'RE
DOING ON HOMELESSNESS OF THIS
LEGISLATION HAS GARNERED THE
SUPPORT OF A SACRAMENTO MAYOR
DARRELL STEINBERG WHO. WAS A CO
CHAIR OF THE GOVERNMENT'S
GOVERNOR'S HOMELESSNESS TASK
FORCE- LA MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI
THE L. A. COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS STOCKTON MAYOR
MICHAEL TUBBS ABSOLUTELY THE
LEADERS ON THAT HAVE SUPPORTED
THIS- AS A WAY. FOR THE STATE
TO PROVIDE MORE SUPPORT TO
THEIR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS- FROM
HOMELESSNESS LIKE COVE IT IT'S
NOT AND URBAN VERSUS RURAL
ISSUE. IT'S A CALIFORNIA ISSUE.
THIS MEASURE HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND IT AND
HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER US AT THIS
MOMENT WE HAVE A MOTION- AS THE
EMOTION OF DO PASSES AS AMENDED
TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS BY
SENATOR PAN ON AB. EIGHTEEN
FORTY FIVE SECRETARY Q. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. AB EIGHTEEN
FORTY FIVE TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS HER
TADO. BY EDITADO AYE JONES.
BELL L. I. JACKSON. ACTION I.
JACKSON ONLINE PAN ALL RIGHT AN
ONLINE MELINDA'S MELINDA'S NO
WINNER I. WIENER ONLINE. THAT'S
FIVE ONE. THE BOAT IS FIVE ONE
AND THAT BILL IS OUT. THANK YOU.
AT THIS MOMENT WE WILL GO AHEAD
AND TAKE UP THE CONSENT.
FOUNDER AND. THE SECRETARY CAN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ANA. WE
HAVE A- THIRD WE HAVE A MOTION
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
POLITICS. WE HAVE A WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR PAN. THANK
YOU. SECRETARY CAN PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY
SIX BLOOM DO YOU PASSED A
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS AB
NINETEEN TWENTY NINE RUBIO DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS AB NINETEEN
SEVENTY NINE FRIEDMAN DO PASSED
A SENATE APPROPRIATIONS AB TWO
SEVEN FOUR SIX GABRIEL DO
PASSED A SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
AB TWO NINE FOUR FOUR STONE DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS. AND B. THREE
ZERO SEVEN THREE WICKS DO
PASSED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS. APARTADO I
FURTADO I JONES JONES BY BELL
BELL I JACKSON. ERIKSSON NINE
JACKSON I CAN I CAN I MELENDEZ
AYE LINDA'S AYE WIENER WIENER
HI AT SEVEN ZERO. THE BILL IS
SEVEN ZERO AND THOSE BILLS ARE
OUT ON CONSENT.
AT THIS MOMENT
ARE WE WILL BE TAKING UP ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT ASSEMBLY BUILT. AT
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY SEVEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON.
REFORMED REMOTELY THROUGH
TELEHEALTH PROVIDED THE CLIENTS
MEET CERTAIN REQUIREMENTS B. I.
HSS PROGRAM IS A MEDIC CAL
BASED PROGRAM THAT IS INTENDED
TO ALLOW LOW INCOME AGED BLIND
AND DISABLED PERSONS INCLUDING
CHILDREN WHO ARE AT RISK FOR
OUT OF HOME PLACEMENT TO REMAIN
SAFELY AT HOME BY PROVIDING
PAYMENT FOR CARE PROVIDERS
SERVICES. IN ORDER TO CONTINUE
ELIGIBILITY FOR IHS US SERVICES
A CLIENT MUST BE REASSESSED
EVERY TWELVE MONTHS AND
REQUIRES A FACE TO FCE HOME
VISIT HOWEVER FOR MANY LOW RISK
I HSS CLIENTS WITH NO CHANGES
IN CIRCUMSTANCES OR LIVING
ARRANGEMENTS IN PERSON ANNUAL
REASSESSMENTS CAN OFTEN BE TIME
CONSUMING AND DIFFICULT TO
SCHEDULE. ANNUAL IN PERSON
ASSESSMENTS ALSO POTENTIALLY
POSE A WORKLOAD PROBLEM FOR
COUNTY SOCIAL WORKERS
ASSESSMENTS REQUIRES
SIGNIFICANT TRAVEL TIME WHICH
LIMITS THE NUMBER OF CLIENTS
THAT CAN BE REACHED IN A SINGLE
DAY FURTHER DELAYING
ASSESSMENTS OR REASSESSMENTS.
BACKLOG OF REASSESSMENTS
NEGATIVELY IMPACTS THE ABILITY
OF COUNTIES TO EFFECTIVELY
ASSESS. RECIPIENT NEEDS. GET
THE INCREASING DEMAND FOR I.
HSS AND WITH THE CURRENT
SITUATION REVOLVES REVOLVING
AROUND COVERT NINETEEN THE
INTRODUCTION OF REMOTE
TELEHEALTH ASSESSMENTS WILL
ALLOW STREAMLINING ANNUAL
REASSESSMENTS. ENSURING
EFFICIENT ACCESS TO SERVICES
WHILE ALSO PROTECTING
VULNERABLE I HSS CLIENTS AN
ESSENTIAL COUNTY SOCIAL
WORKERS. I ALSO REALIZE THAT
THERE MAY BE CONCERNS REGARDING
THIS BILL AND THE BRANCH TO
PROVIDE I JOIN ASSESSMENTS SO
IN PERSON HOWEVER WE HAVE MADE
EVERY EFFORT TO PROVIDE THE
NECESSARY SAFEGUARDS IN ORDER
TO PROTECT CLIENTS. THAT TO NOT
LET THEM FALL THROUGH THE
CRACKS THRUGH THE THROUGH THE
CRACKS THIS BILL ONLY CREATES
THE OPTION FOR COUNTIES TO
PROVIDE REMOTE TELEHEALTH US
ASSESSMENTS FOR EXTREMELY LOW
RISK CLIENTS. BUT IT DOES NOT
MAKE IT MANDATORY WELL THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
ALREADY ALLOWS THIS TEMPORARILY
WE BELIEVE THAT IT'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT TO HAVE PERMANENT
STRUCTURES IN PLACE. TO
CONTINUE TO PROTECT VULNERABLE
CLIENTS FROM COVERT NINETEEN OR
ANY POSSIBLE FUTURE EMERGENCIES
SO WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE TRACY MURRAY DIRECTOR
OF AGING AND ADULT SERVICES.
CONTRA. COSTA EMPLOYMENT AND
HUMAN SERVICES. THANK YOU WE
WILL NOT OPEN IT UP TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF TO
CONSIDER THE LINK MEANS POLICY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS WE WILL INSTITUTE
TIME LIMITS ON TESTIMONY.
ACCORDINGLY WITNESS IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION WILL BE LIMITED
TO A TOTAL OF THREE MINUTES.
AND UP PLEASE. PLEASE DO NOT
FORGET TO UPDATE YOURSELF ON ME
WHEN YOU WERE NOT SPEAKING.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS TRACY
MURRAY THE DIRECTOR OF AGING
AND ADULT SERVICES. FOR CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY AND I AM VERY
PLEASED TO BE HERE TODAY. TO
EXPRESS MY SUPPORT OF AB TWO
THREE EIGHT SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON. AS YOU
ARE AWARE THIS BILL WILL ALLOW
PERMANENTLY POOR TELEPHONIC
REASSESSMENT FOR THE IN HOME
SUPPORT SERVICES PROGRAM. ALSO
KNOWN AS I. HSS. I SENIORS OVER
SIXTY FIVE SAME OLD AND BLIND
INDIVIDUAL PAPER SERVICES
PROVIDED TO THEM SO THAT THEY
CAN REMAIN SAFELY IN THEIR
HOMES. AS YOU HAVE HEARD I HSS
IS THE FASTEST GROWING SOCIAL
SERVICE PROGRAM IN MANY
COUNTIES INCLUDING CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY. IN OUR COUNTY WE HAVE
MORE THAN ELEVEN THOUSAND
CONSUMERS AND AN ANNUAL GROWTH
RATE THAT EXCEEDS EIGHT
PERCENT. WE'VE SEEN. THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHERE
WE EXPECT. BY TWENTY. EVERY
RUBIO THE AGE OF SIXTY. GIVEN
THE GROWING DEMAND AND RESOURCE.
COUNTY MUST. BE ABLE TO MEET.
CENTERED AND PROVIDE AND HAVE
PROVIDED CENTER ALTERNATIVE
THAT ARE BOTH RESPONSIVE AND
EFFICIENT IN ORDER TO MEET
CLIENTS IN HOME CARE NEEDS.
CALVET NINE PANDEMIC IN STATE.
PLACE HAS HI THE NEED FOR
ALTERNATIVE TELEPHONIC VIDEO
AND OTHER MEANS OF
COMMUNICATION WITH VULNERABLE
CLIENT POPULATIONS WHO WISHED
TO REMAIN IN QUARANTINE AT
HOME. CURRENTLY HAS YOUR
WORKERS ARE ABLE TO CONDUCT
TELEPHONIC REASSESSMENTS FOR I.
HSS. WE KNOW THAT ASSESSMENTS
HAVE GAINED GROUND AND OTHER
PRO INCLUDING WORK MANY AND
INTERVIEWING. OUR FRESH WE
BELIEVE IT IS VERY TO OPERATE
SAME DEGREE OF ACCESS. TO IT
JEFF CONSUMERS. WE THE TALIBAN
AND REASSESSMENTS ARE IN
ADDITION TOOL AVAILABLE TO
SOCIAL WORKERS AND I HSS
RECIPIENTS PROVIDING
FLEXIBILITY CONVENIENCE FOR
CONSUMERS AND EFFICIENCIES FOR
COUNTY. IN THE CURRENT
ENVIRONMENT WE HAVE A FEEDBACK
FROM MANY I HSS CONSUMER TO
EXPRESSED APPRECIATION FOR THE
ABILITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
ANNUAL REASSESSMENT OVER THE
PHONE. AND WE KNOW THAT
TELEPHONICALLY ASSESSED HELP
KEEP OUR CONSUMERS AND WORKERS
HEALTHY. I UNDERSTAND TRACK.
HELLO CHRISTMAS ENABLES WORKERS
GOT MORE TIME DEVOTED TO
RESPONDING TO I. HFS CONSUMER
EIGHT. PASSAGE OF THIS BILL
WOULD PREVENT HFS RECIPIENT'S
CHOICE BUT HOW THEY ARE UPSET.
AND WOULD PRESERVE OPTIONS BY
ALLOWING ANYONE TO OPT IN FOR
ANY IN PERSON REASSESSMENT EVEN
AFTER TELEPHONIC ASSESSMENTS
HAVE BEEN OFFERED. IN SUMMARY
JAPANESE ARE CURRENTLY
TEMPORARILY ALLOWED TO CONDUCT
TELEPHONE REASSESSMENTS FOR I.
HFS RECIPIENTS AND WE RECOMMEND
HOW TO FIND THESE OPTIONS AS
CONTAINED IN AB. TWO THREE
EIGHT SEVEN. NUMBER UFC FIGHT
THE CURRENT AND ON GOING THE
FOR NEW. AND I'M TRYING SUCH AS
WITH PRESENTED WITH THIS. HI
HELLO. THANK YOU HELLO THANK.
CAN YOU PLEASE PUT YOURSELF ON
MUTE. THANK YOU. OKAY. TWENTY
DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING TO ADD AT
THIS MOMENT. ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS. NO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO AT THIS MOMENT WE WILL
INVITE THE PUBLIC TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT AND WE'LL START WITH
ROOM FORTY TWO ZERO THREE
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION A POSITION ONLY.
SCENE NINE AND ROOM FORTY TWO
ZERO THREE WE WILL GO AHEAD AND
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE AS A
REMINDER TO THE WAITING ON THE
PHONE PLEASE LIMIT YOUR
TESTIMONY TO NAME AFFILIATION
YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL-
MODERATOR PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY. THREE
EIGHTY SEVEN. PORT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE FALLEN WE WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN IF ZERO AT THIS TIME
THAT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO ONE
MOMENT PLEASE.
AND WE DO HAVE
ONE QUEUING UP WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER SEVENTY EIGHT THAT SEVEN
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THE MORNING WHAT THE
ARC AND UCPE CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATION IN SUPPORT. THERE
IS NO ONE ELSE IN THE PUBLIC
YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
MODERATE CAN YOU PLEASE CHECK
OUT ONCE MORE. TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAPTURED ALL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY SEVEN. ONCE AGAIN IT'S
ONE THEN ZERO TO PLACE YOURSELF
IN TWO Q. FOR SUPPORT. AND
THERE IS STILL NO ONE ELSE
SHOWING UP AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU. HAVEN'T HEARD FROM ALL THE
SUPPORTERS WILL NOT POLICY
PROCESS FOR ALL OF THOSE. HE
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION I. DO YOU HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. THREE
NINE DO WE HAVE ANY OF IN ROOM
FORTY TWO ZERO THREE. NOW AT
THIS MOMENT WILL MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELEPHONE THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS. SAMATAR
YOU PLEASE PUMP INDIVIDUALS
WANTING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY SEVEN AND PROVIDE THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE READY TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. HE ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK
OUT IN OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THERE IS NO ONE SHOWING UP IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU CAN BARBECUE PLUS PLEASE
CHECK ONCE MORE TO MAKE SURE WE
HAVE CAPTURED ALL WITNESSES.
OPPOSED TO AB TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY SEVEN. THANK YOU IF YOU
ARE POSES BILLION A PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME TO PLACE
YOURSELF IN TWO Q. ONCE AGAIN
WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE QUEUING
UP. IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU AT
THIS MOMENT WILL MOVE TO.
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. BILL THANK
YOU. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU SO MUCH OF THE STAFF
ENSURE FOR THE GOOD WORK ON
THIS- BILL AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL THANK YOU WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR PAN OF TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO SENATE FLOOR.
SECRETARY GENERAL AB TWO THREE
EIGHT SEVEN BY GRAYSON THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
SENATE FLOOR HER TADO HI TATO I
JONES JONES HI BELLE BELLE I
JACKSON JACKSON HI JACKSON I
PAN ALL RIGHT AND I MELINDA'S.
WIENER WIENER I THAT SIX ZERO.
THE VOTE WAS SIX ZERO WILL PUT
THAT BILL ON CALL. THANK YOU Q.
SO AT THIS MOMENT WE WILL TAKE
UP AGENDA ITEM SIX A. B. TWO
ONE SEVEN FOUR BY GALLAGHER AND
HAVE A STANDARD. ON THE BILL
TODAY. THANK YOU MAN SHERMAN
SENATORS SO I'M PRESENTING THIS
BILL ON BEHALF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER WHICH WOULD AUTHORIZE
YUBA AND SUTTER COUNTIES TO
FORM A JOINT HOMELESS MULTI
DISCIPLINARY PERSONNEL THIS
TEAM WOULD FACILITATE
INFORMATION SHARING. TO SUPPORT
THE IDENTIFICATION ASSESSMENT
AND LEAKAGE OF HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS TO THEIR HOUSING
AND SUPPORT SERVICES. THESE
THESE- TEAMS ARE PROVEN TOOL
THAT ALLOWS TEAMS OF VARYING
VARYING DISCIPLINES TO
COORDINATE THEIR EFFORTS AND
HAVE BEEN SEARCHED SUCCESSFULLY
USED FOR THE PAST THIRTY YEARS
TO ADDRESS CHILD ABUSE OR
NEGLECT. A SERVICE PROVIDERS TO
WORK TOGETHER TO SHARE CASE
INFORMATION RECENTLY- HUH- THEY
HAVE BEEN USED FOR HOMELESSNESS
UNFORTUNATELY OUR CURRENT LAW
LIMITS THE UTILIZATION OF
HALMOS MULTI DISCIPLINARY TEAMS
TO PROVIDERS WITHIN A SINGLE
COUNTY THIS CAN BE PROBLEMATIC
FOR COUNTIES THAT WISH TO.
COORDINATE SERVICES ACROSS
COUNTY LINES- LIKE YUBA AND
SUTTER. IN COORDINATION AND
INFORMATION SHARING MAKES A LOT
OF SENSE FOR THESE COUTIES AS
THEY ALREADY SHARE HOMELESS
SERVICE PROVIDERS HAVE A BY
COUNTY HEALTH DEPARTMENT. AND
I'VE CREATED A BY COUNTY
HOMELESS CONSORTIUM THE BILL
WOULD- HELP YEAH EFFORTS TO
PROVIDE HOUSING AND SUPPORT
SERVICES TO HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS. YEAH WHICH ARE
STRICTLY CRITICAL- DURING OUR
COVERT NINETEEN CRISIS THAT
WE'VE SEEN OUR HOMELESS
POPULATION. IS PARTICULARLY
VULNERABLE DURING THIS CRISIS.
THE INCREASE COORDINATION-
BETWEEN THE COUNTIES WOULD ALSO
CREATE A COST SAVINGS AND
IMPROVE GOVERNMENT EFFICIENCY
BY PREVENTING DUPLICATIVE
EFFORTS- THROUGH BETTER
COORDINATION WHILE ENHANCING
CONTINUE CONTINUE OF CARE FOR
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES. AND THIS TIME THE
SPEAKERS FROM. SUTTER COUNTY
ADULT SERVICES BRANCH DIRECTOR
FROM HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
MARK MARK SHOOTS LEMIRE. AND
SHE LOOKED DARK GLASIER FROM
YUBA COUNTY TELL WORKS HOMELESS
PROJECT MANAGER SO I'LL TURN IT
OVER THE SPEAKERS. HI THIS IS
MARC SPORTS MYRON THEY- FELT
BRANCH DIRECTOR I WOULD LIKE TO
DECEMBER IN THAT THE BILL
SIMPLY TAKES THE EXISTING HOMES
MULTI DISCIPLINARY TEAM STATUTE
AND ALLOW SUTTER AND YUBA
COUNTIES TOGETHER UNDER THE
SAME PARAMETERS- ALSO THE
SCIENTISTS I SAID THE BILL
DOESN'T EXPAND OR CHANGE
PRIVACY RIGHTS. OF INDIVIDUALS
WHAT'S ARE ALLOWED EXISTING
HOMELESS MULTI DISCIPLINARY
TEAM STATUTES SO INTO OF IT SO
WHAT WE WOULD DO WANT TO GIVE A
MORE BACK ABOUT CENTERS IN YOU
THE- EACH BIKE HOMELESS BE. WE
CREATED A UP TO THAT WAS FOCUS
ON A MY COUNTY CALLED A SINGLE.
AND RESOLUTIONS WHAT THE SAME
DOESN'T SOCIAL SERVICES
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS AND ONE. REGIONAL
MULTI DISCIPLINARY TEAM. AND
THIS TEAM PROVIDE EXTENSIVE
SUPPORT AND LINKAGE TO SERVICES
IN AN EFFORT TO CONDUCT.
COMPASSIONATE KERN FORTUNATE
FOR OUR HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS.
HUMBOLDT COUNTY'S ALL FOR
THIRTY MINUTES UNITS ABOUT
EACH. WE'VE ALL. GROUPE. THE
SHARED AND YOU THAT WILL THE
MOST DISCIPLINARY TEAMS OPERATE
IN ALL THE JURORS. SO THIS BILL
WILL HELP TO SOLVE A CRITICAL
PIECE OF THE WORK THAT THE TEAM
WILL DO. AS WITH OTHER MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAMS BEING ABLE
TO SHARE BASIC INFORMATION ON
TEAM MEMBERS OF THE CENTRAL. TO
ACCOMPLISHING THE MISSION OF
THE TEAM AND AS YOU'RE AWARE
HOMELESS IS HOMELESSNESS THE-
COME ISSUE. DRESSER
COMMUNICATION AMONG THOSE
TRYING TO SOLVE IT. IS A BASIC
REQUIREMENT FOR OUR SUCCESS. AS
A TEAM START YOUR JOURNEY TO A
PLACE OF TREMENDOUS AMOUNT FOR.
US SO FAR IN TWO. A COOPERATIVE
APPROACH AND WITHOUT PASSAGE OF
THIS BILL WILL BE VERY
DIFFICULT TO ACCOMPLISH OUR
MISSION OF ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS IN OUR REGION. YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND A CLIENT
DELETED NOT GONNA SHARE SOME
INFORMATION FROM YOU COUNTY.
GOOD MORNING KAREN CENTER KILEY
VEHICLE MANAGER HOMELESS
HOUSING INITIATIVES IN YUBA
COUNTY THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION SUPPORTING THE
AUTHORIZATION OF THE BY COUNTY
HOMELESS MULTI DISCIPLINARY
TEAM. IF YOU LOOK ON OUR
DEVELOPMENT IS IN DIRECT
RESPONSE TO A LOT OF
COORDINATION OF. SERVICES
BETWEEN. CURRENT RESTRICTS WITH
CAN YOU TO A SINGLE PAYER AND
HAS COME TO THE CREATION OF AB
TWENTY ONE FOUR EXPAND EXISTING
BY A OUR TWO COUNTIES ESTABLISH
A BY COUNTY M. ET SURE MISSION
RELEVANT THE DALLAS INDIVIDUALS
ENTERTAINING HOUSING AND
SERVICES ALMOST POPULATION IN
YUBA AND SUTTER COUNTIES IS
HISTORICALLY FLUENT. TRANSIENT
AND DURING THE TO THE NINETEEN
BY COUNTY POINT IN TIME COUNT
20% EACH TURNING HOMELESS IT
CLEANS UP THERE LAST RESIDENTS
WITHIN THE NEIGHBORING
JURISDICTIONS MIGRATION OF THE
TRIP TO COUNTIES MAKES IT
DIFFICULT TO PROVIDE CONTINUOUS
SERVICES ENSURING BOTH CITIZENS
EXPECTED MY WHICH PROMPTED
ACTIVITIES INCLUDING CREEK IN
ABOUT A MONTH OR YOU GOT. SIX
BY COUNTY SERVICE PROGRAM INTO
THE- EIGHTEEN AND OF I COUNTY
HOMELESS TASK FORCE FROM THE
COUNTY TO BEGIN THE RESPONSE
COVER NINE. AND MY EARLIER THIS
YEAR. THE INTO OF THE TO COUNTY
HAS TRIED TO BEEN COOPER.
DIRECTING RESOURCES TO THE RICH
OF. RATHER IN THE TO BE. OF AS
MANY OF THOSE SERVICES.
TOGETHER ARE GIVE YOU MORE TO
ADVANCE OUR EFFORTS THEN WE
COULD ACCOMPLISH THAT
SEPARATELY. AND YOUR APPROVAL
OF AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY FOUR
WILL PROVIDE A FRAMEWORK TO
EFFECTIVELY GET. ARE YOU BY
CHANCE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU AT
THIS POINT WE WILL TAKE OUR-
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO A.
B. TWO ONE SEVEN FOUR. BACK AT
KRAMER I HAVE A SEAT CANNOT ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU CALIFORNIA
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
UNLESS AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
FOUR AND THANKS THE ENDING THE
MULTI DISCIPLINARY TEAM
MEMBERSHIP ACROSS COUNTY
BOUNDARIES AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY FOUR INCREASES THE
REACH OF HOW FAR CONFIDENTIAL
INFORMATION ABOUT A PERSON
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS HE
SHARED WITHOUT THAT PERSON'S
CONSENT. THEREBY EXACERBATING
THE PRIVACY ISSUES WITH ALMOST
MULTI DISCIPLINARY. HE GREAT
SHARING AN INTERNET ACROSS
AGENCIES AND PROGRAM CAN
IMPROVE. AND IT'S A- WITH A DRY
HOW MUCH. BUT IT WAS MUST BE
BALANCED BY HONORING CREDIT THE
INTEREST OF THE INDIVIDUAL THAT
YOU IS TRYING TO FERRET AND
RECOGNIZING THE IMPORTANCE
PURPOSE PRIVATE SEEKS TO
ACHIEVE. ONE FIFTY MONTANA
UNLIMITED CREDIT SHARING A
COMPANY AND AMONG MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAM. PROVIDER IS.
NOW MISS A CALL. ADEQUATELY IN
BUT THE COMP INFORMATION HE
THOUGHT THE HOMELESSNESS IS NOT
SHARED WITHOUT THEIR CONSENT.
THE LACK OF ANY OPT IN OR OPT
OUT MECHANISM FOR HAVING AN
INDIVIDUAL CONFIDENTIAL
INFORMATION SHARED BY MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAM MEMBERS OR
PROVIDER AGENCY. OR NOT A VERY
REAL. REST THAT INDIVIDUAL.
ORIN KERR STRAIGHT PEOPLE USING
THESE SERVICES. MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAM THAN OTHER
CONTACT INCLUDING DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING
LOOK AT IT WHEN I SEE. FIRETEAM
MEMBERS OBTAINED INFORMED
WRITTEN CONSENT FROM AN
INDIVIDUAL BEFORE DISCLOSING
THEM UPDATED SHE- INDIVIDUAL.
AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY FOUR
SHOULD BE AMENDED TO LIKEWISE
ACQUIRED A YUBA SUTTER MONTHLY
NAY TEAM MEMBER WHO FIRST
ESTABLISHED IN CONTACT WITH AN
INDIVIDUAL OR ANYTHING
HOMELESSNESS AND NOT INDIVIDUAL
OF INFORMED CONSENT FOR ABOUT
INFORMATION SHARING. ONLY THE
JOBS YOU LEAVE THERE RIGHT.
HUNDRED ASSEMBLY BY VIRTUE OF
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
ACCIDENT ABSENT CONFIDENTIALITY
PROVISIONS LIKE THE HEAD AND
I'VE HAD MATH MATHEMATIC BETTER
THE ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY.
WELL YEAH. THANK YOU AT THIS
MOMENT WE WILL INVITE PUBLIC
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
ONE SEVEN FOUR AND WILL BEGIN
WITH THE ROOM FORTY TWO ZERO
THREE. SEEN WILL MOVE ON OVER
TO THE TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMENT
LINE AND PLEASE REMEMBER TO
JUST STATE YOUR- NAME A
POSITION IN OF AN AFFILIATION.
THANK YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
THE PHONE LINES TO SHOW SUPPORT
FOR THIS YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME TO PUT
YOURSELF INTO THE QUEUE. WE DO
HAVE ONE QUEUE AT THIS TIME
WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER FORTY
NINE FOUR NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING NOT
INSURANCE. I WILL BRING YOU THE
COUNTY OR CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
ONE TWENTY ONE SEVENTY FOUR
THANK YOU. AS A REMINDER YOU
MAY PLACE YOURSELF IN THE QUEUE
FOR SUPPORT BY PRESSING ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. THERE
IS NO ONE QUEUING UP AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU HAVING HEARD
FROM ALL THE SUPPORTERS WE WILL
NOW FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS TO
HEAR FROM. ALL THOSE THAT WANT
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS. TO THIS
BILL AB TWO ONE SEVEN FOUR AND
WILL BEGIN IN ROOM FORTY TWO
ZERO THREE. C. NINE WILL MOVE
ON OVER TO THE TELEPHONE PUBLIC
LINE. PLEASE REMEMBER TO STATE
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL MODERATOR
PLEASE PUMP INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWO ONE SEVEN. BY THE- THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO PROVIDE
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. NO ONE INTO IT THIS TIME
AS A REMINDER YOU MAY. PRESS
OPPOSITION BY PRESSING ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND THERE IS
NO OPPOSITION FROM THE PHONE
LINES AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
AT THIS MOMENT WILL GO AHEAD
AND MOVE OVER TO COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OF THE BILL. THE
QUESTION. AND WE HAVE A CENTER
HANNAH BETH JACKSON. IT'S THANK
YOU I JUST WANTED TO COMMENT ON
THE PRIVACY ISSUE BECAUSE THAT
IS IMPORTANT THE BILL UNDER
NORMAL CIRCUMSTANCES WOULD HAVE
COME TO THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
BECAUSE OF THAT ELEMENT- AND
IT. ALTHOUGH THOSE ARE VALID
CONCERNS THAT THEY GET TO
EXISTING LAW AND NOT TO THE
BILL ITSELF SO THIS ADDRESSES A
SITUATION WITHIN TO COUNTIES-
WHERE THEY ARE JUST SIMPLY
ASKING FOR THE ABILITY TO-
APART PAID. USING EXISTING LAWS
AND IT'S MY HOPE THAT IN THE
FUTURE- WE DO ADDRESS THIS I
THINK THE CONCERNS OF THE ACLU
DO HAVE. SOME VALIDITY TO THEM
SIGNIFICANT POLITICALLY HOW IT
COMES TO. INSURING THAT ARE
HOMELESS HAVE THE SAME RIGHTS
AS OTHERS AND THAT- WE KNOW
THAT EXISTING LAW DOESN'T
NECESSARILY RESPECT THE ON A
TON OF MANY OF THE AND
SHELTERED BUT- GIVEN THE FACT
THAT THIS BILL JUST SIMPLY-
OPERATES UNDER EXISTING LAW.
AND WE'RE NOT BEING ASKED TO
REEVALUATE THOSE PROPERTY
RIGHTS MY HOPE FUTURE LUNCH
WILL HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY SO
I'M GOING TO SUPPORT THE BILL
RIGHT I DO WHAT I DID IN HIGH.
THAT THERE ARE SOME SIGNIFICANT
PRIVACY ISSUES- THAT SHOULD BE
INTERESTING IN FUTURE
LEGISLATION. THANK. SEVEN
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE REQUEST.
OKAY SO WHAT MOMENTO WILL ALLOW
FOR ANOTHER CLOSE FROM OF
ASSEMBLY GALLAGHER. THIS MAY
NOT BE THE OFF PER BUT IT'S PRO
MINE I THE OFFER TO SPEAK IT'S
A GOOD THING TO ENCOURAGE THE
SMALLER COUNTIES TO FORM
CONSORTIUMS TO PROVIDE HUMAN
SERVICES BECAUSE IT ALLOWS THEM
TO HAVE A WIDE ARRAY OF RATE.
OF SUCH PROCESSES THEY CAN
PROVIDE THEIR CONSTITUENTS ARE
I THINK THAT'S A GOOD THING
THEY SHOULD TAKE ADVANTAGE
DEFICIENCY OF DOING MARGIN I
VOTE ON THIS. THANK YOU SENATE
SENATOR BELL AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE A MOTION OF TO PASS TO
SENATE FLOOR BY SENATOR JONES.
ON AB. TWO ONE SEVEN FOUR.
SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. AB TWO ONE SEVEN FOUR
BY GALLAGHER THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED THE SENATE FLOOR HER
TADO HI RICARDO I JONES JONES
FIVE BELL. BELL I JACKSON
ACTION. JACKSON ONLINE PAN. BY
HAND AYE MELINDA'S AYE
MELINDA'S AYE WIENER. WIENER
AYE THAT'S SEVEN ZERO. THE BILL
IS SEVEN ZERO IN THE BILL IS
OUT. MOVING ON WE WILL TAKE UP
AGENDA ITEM NUMBER SEVEN A. B.
TWO THREE SEVEN SEVEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHU. ON BEHALF SENATOR.
SURE MA'AM THIS BILL IN TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY SEVEN- WILL
REDUCE HOMELESSNESS AND HELP
RESIDENTS OF ADULT RESIDENTIAL
FACILITIES BY SERVICING A
STRONGER CLOSURE REQUIREMENTS
GIVING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THE
TOOLS THEY NEED TO ENSURE THESE
CRITICAL FACILITIES THEY OPEN
AND COMMUNITIES. THESE SERVE
OUR STATE'S MOST VULNERABLE
RESIDENTS INDIVIDUAL SERVICE
MENTAL ILLNESS AND OTHER
CHRONIC CONDITIONS NO LONGER
ABLE TO LIVE SAFELY AND
INDEPENDENTLY. RECENT YEARS
THESE FACILITIES HAVE CLOSED
AND MARAMING RATE LEAVING THE
RESIDENCE AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS DURING THE HOUSING
CRISIS- SINCE ADULT RESIDENTIAL
FACILITIES CLOSING REQUIREMENTS
ARE LESS PROTECTIVE. THE THAN
FOR OTHER BOARD AND CARE
FACILITIES THE BILL REQUIRE
ADULT RESIDENTIAL- FACILITIES
OPERATORS TO PROVIDE SIX MONTHS
NOTICE. TO ROAD. PRIOR TO YOUR-
GOVERNMENT THE FOR. THE
FACILITY AND PROVIDE LOWER REAL
OKAY AND PLANNED FOR ALL
RESIDENTS AND ALLOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THE FLEXIBILITY OF
USING MENTAL HEALTH AND
HOMELESS PREVENTION FOCUS
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE- WE URGE THE
THAT THIS BILL BE SUPPORTED
BECAUSE WE NEED TO PREPARE FOR
A POTENTIAL SPIKE. IN ALL
ALMOST A SURPRISE TO PROGRAM
NINETEENTH CAN DO I HAVE SOME
WITH. SERVED KELLY HERE MOTO
FROM THE SAN FRANCISCO TO OF
PUBLIC. FOR THE SITTING COUNTY
SAN FRANCISCO STATE BISHARA
FROM THE EAST BAY SUPPORTER
HOUSING COLLABORATIVE THE
WITNESSES MEASURE. THANK WE
WILL OUR- MANY MEN THANK GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING GOOD
MORNING SHARING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS KELLY THAT'S
THE PROJECT MANAGER AT THE TIME.
WELL I'M A HAPPEN MAYOR BREED
IN THE CITY IN COUNTY OF SAN
THAT'S GOING WANT TO THANK. OF
THE DAY. PRESIDENT BUSH AND IN
FULL I WANT TO THANK MY NUMBER
AGAIN CHIU FOR THE PART. I'M
CALLING TO THE GARDEN ISSUE I'M
HERE TO PRESENT THE CAR UP
MONEY FOR DOG. THAT SEVEN AB
TWENTY THREE. THE REST OF ON
THE AT THE END OF A CARE
FACILITY THANK HUNDRED TWENTY
THREE. MANAGE ACCOUNT. I DON'T
RESIDENTS FACILITIES ARE AND
RESIDENTS CARE BUT FOR THE
ELDERLY GARCIA BURKE CONNELLY
REFRIGERATE FOR. INTERVAL I
THINK SOME OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE RESIDENTS RESIDENTS
CAMPUS AFTER SUPPORTER
RESIDENTIAL FOR IN THE WHO ARE
NOT CURRENTLY IN A SAFE ON. THE
LIKE MANY OTHER PARTS OF THE
CAR THE STATE EXPERIENCE AND
CRAP LOT ABOUT CAMPAIGN. YES
LOTS OF INCREASING YEAR BETWEEN
TWENTY TWELVE AND TWENTY NINE.
A LOT FORTY FACILITY TWO
HUNDRED FORTY THREE THAT COULD
YOU POINT THIRTY CHRIS DECLINE
IN THE. THAT PLACE CLIENTS AND
THE PRESIDENTIAL FACILITY THE
OFTEN THE IN YOUR WHAT HAPPENED
THREE NEED FOR. ARM HE MANY
UPPER EVENT NOW THE HAVE COMP
MEDICAL. HOW MUCH. MONEY YOU
WILL PROVIDE A BASIC NEEDS LIKE
SHELTER THANK NOT CURRENTLY
REAL OR TEMPERATURE FOR
RESIDENTS FROM OURS YEAH OURS
IN THE YOUR OUR THE RIGHT TO
GET FOR EACH OF THE- RCF I
THINK LEVEL PROTECTION.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO THREE SEVEN
SEVEN WOULD ADDRESS THAT ISSUE
BY ALIGNING OUR CULTURE
REQUIREMENTS AND THOSE OF OUR
FIFTY ENSURING THAT THEY ARE
PRESIDENT OF. REJECTION THAT
PARTY AT THE RED AB ONE SILICON.
THE BILL WILL FOR THE REST OF
THE AND PROBLEM RELATED TO KOBE
NINETEEN CREDIT CATHERINE AND
SERVICES COULD THAT IN FUTURE
VERSIONS HERE. RESPONSE
BRAMPTON ARE CLOSED REQUIRE
HELLO WILL BE ABLE REDUCE RISK
OF HARM PROTECT SOME OF THE
MOBILE BOOKS. THE FUTURE PUBLIC
HEALTH CARE. I WANT TO THANK
YOU. FEDERATION. TO REMIND
WOMEN AND SUPPORT THE WE HAVE A
TOTAL OF TWO MINUTES FOR BOTH.
YES HI I AM STEVE BISHOP FROM
THE EAST BAY SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
COLLABORATIVE THIS IS A GROUP
OF DEDICATED TO INCREASING OF
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
FOR PEOPLE OF SEARCHERS MELIS.
HERE IS AN IMPORTANT SOURCE OF.
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
FOR PEOPLE. WHO NEED SUPPORT IN
ORDER TO HAVE A HOUSING AND IT
SHOULD. TWENTY THREE SEVENTY
SEVEN IS VERY IMPORTANT IN A
COUPLE OF WAYS ONE IS THAT. IT
ALLOWS ACTUALLY MANDATE. FOR
PLANNING FOR A RESIDENT OF THE
CITIZENS ABILITY TO HAVE SOME
OTHER PLACE TO LIVE. YES THAT
WAS SIMPLY GOING TO BE CLOSING.
AS NOTED BEFORE I THINK THAT
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WASN'T
ALWAYS AVAILABLE TO. PEOPLE IN
ADULT RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES AS
WELL AS YEAH RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITY FOR THE ELDERLY. THE
OTHER THING THAT'S IN VERY
IMPORTANT IS THE UP PUBLIC
ENEMY RIGHT OF COURSE TO
PURCHASE THE PROPERTY IF IT'S
GOING TO BE FOR SALE. AND IT'S
IMPORTANT IN A COUPLE WAYS ONE
IS THAT IT GIVES. THE LOCAL
AUTHORITY IT'S TIME TO DECIDE
IF IT WANTS TO PURCHASE A
FACILITY IF THAT MAKES SENSE.
AND THEN IT WAS TIME TO TRY AND
PUT TOGETHER THE MONEY IN ORDER
TO DO THAT- WHICH IS NOT NEXT
YEAR EITHER LEADER. I AM VERY
SHORT PROCESS. SO HAVING A
EIGHTY DAYS VERY IMPORTANT IN
THE CASE. SO A YES WHAT I'D
LIKE TO SAY IN ASSEMBLY IS JUST
THIS IS. A IMPORTANT BILL TO
PAY WHO NEED FOR CORPORATES FOR
THOUSAND AND SPACE OF. HAS
CLEVER. ENCOURAGES YOU TO PAY
IT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU THIS
MOMENT WE INVITE COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY SEVEN AND WILL BEGIN
WITH ROOM. FORTY TWO ZERO
THREE. CNN WE WILL GO AHEAD AND
MOVE ON TO THE TELEPHONE LINE.
WE WILL A SOLUTION WHEN IT HAS
A FIVE YEAR THE TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE THERE'S A REMINDER TO
THOSE- THAT ARE WAITING TO JUST
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION IN YOUR POSITION ON
THE BILL MODERATOR PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WANT WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SEVEN. AND
PROVIDE THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
PEOPLE. BAKER THIS TIME WE HAVE
SIX LINES IN IN Q. AND AS A
REMINDER LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO QUEUE UP
WILL PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME BUT EIGHTEEN T.
SPECIALIST WILL GIVE YOU
INFORMATION. THEN YOU CAN
REMOVE. ON THEN ZERO. GO TO THE
LINE EIGHTY TWO GO AHEAD PLEASE.
ANY OFFER WITH CLAYTON VISORS
REPRESENTING THE NATIONAL
ALLIANCE ON MENTAL ILLNESS ALSO
NOT A CALIFORNIA SUPPORT THANK.
NEXT WE GO TO LINE FIFTY NINE
BOWHEAD PLEASE. BACK IN BALANCE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. IT IS LINE FORTY NINE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING TYLER
ENDED WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. THE
LITTLE EIGHTY FIVE GO AHEAD.
NATIONAL ALLIANCE ON MENTAL
ILLNESS BAY AFFILIATE IN
SUPPORT. AND SHE'LL. THE NEXT
TO LINE FIFTY GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING KATHLEEN SECARA I'M NOT
SURE OF THE EAST BAY SUPPORTED
HOUSING COLLABORATIVE PARENT IN
ADULTS WITH SERIOUS MENTAL
ILLNESS CALLING IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. RECORDER LINE EIGHTY
SIX GO AHEAD PLEASE. DIGIDAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF ALAMEDA
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND AS A
REMINDER IF YOU DO WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'LL GO TO
LINE SIXTY EIGHT. ACTUALLY
SIDED WITH THE AMERICAN
INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU ARE HAVING
HEARD FROM ALL SUPPORTERS WE
WILL NOW FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS FOR ALL THOSE WITH. FOR
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. TO AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SEVEN. AND
WE WILL BEGIN WITH ROOM FORTY
TWO ZERO THREE. C. NINE WE WILL
GO AHEAD AND MOVE ON OVER TO
THE TELEPHONE LINE. SO MODERATE
IS PUMPED INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SEVEN. AND
PROVIDE THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. REGULATORS IN
GERMAN AS REMINDER PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. WE DO HAVE ONE NINE
IN Q. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. WE'LL
GO TO LINE FORTY TWO GO AHEAD
PLEASE. YES MADAM CHAIR THIS IS
BOB NAYLOR I REPRESENT SIX BEDS
IN COACHES ASSOCIATION OF
ASSISTED LIVING FACILITIES
ADULT RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES
ABOUT TWO THOUSAND OF THEM WE
REGRETTABLY HAVE TO OPPOSE THE
BILL BECAUSE OF THE- RIGHT OF
FIRST REFUSAL. ON THE ADDITION
OF THE FAIR MARKET VALUE
STANDARD WE THINK THAT IS
UNFAIR TO OWNERS OF THEY ARE UP
TO SUPPORT EVERY OTHER
PROVISION THE BILL. AND WILL
DISCUSS IN THE AND THEY ARE US
NEED TO BE A- THANK YOU. AND AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
TO UP. THANK YOU MODERATE CAN.
YOU JUST MAKE SURE TO CHECK THE
ONE ONCE MORE TO MAKE SURE
WE'VE HEARD FROM ALL WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY SEVEN. THE ONCE
AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
KNOWN QUEUED UP SPEAK AT THIS
TIME. AT THIS MOMENT WE WILL GO
AHEAD AND MOVE OVER TO- ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THE BILL. SO
I WILL GO AHEAD AND AN CENTER
BILL WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I
WROTE THANK. HAVE A MOTOR.
SEVENTY SEVEN. SECRETARY KING
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB DO YOU
PASSED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE HER
DAUGHTER. RICARDO I. KNOW NO- I
JACKSON JACKSON I. JACKSON I
PAN BY HAND HI MELINDA MULLIN
NO WINNER OR WINNERS I. THAT'S
FIVE TWO. THE BILL IS FIVE TWO
AND THE BILL IS OUT. UP NEXT WE
HAVE AGENDA ITEM NUMBER TEN. BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON WAS
HERE TO SPEAK AND PRESENT ON AB
TWENTY NINE TWENTY SIX WELCOME
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- FIRST I'D LIKE TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
FOUND IN THE CAMINO ALICE'S
WILL LIKE TO THANK THE STAFF
FROM BOTH IS THE INCIDENT FOR
THE- HELLO. THIS MEMBERS AB
TWENTY NINE TWENTY SIX IS A
BILL SEEKING TO ENSURE THERE
ARE REGULATIONS IN PLACE ON
REFERRAL SOURCES AND THEIR
INTERACTIONS WITH SENIORS AND
THEIR FAMILIES REFERRAL SOURCES
OR ENTITIES THAT PROVIDE
REFERRALS TO RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITIES FOR THE ELDERLY
GARCIA FEES FOR SHORT TO
SENIORS OR THE REPRESENTATIVES
WHILE BUSINESS MODELS AND VERY
QUICKLY THIS SERVICE IS
PROVIDED WITHOUT COST THE
SENIOR THEIR FAMILY AND PEARL
SPURS GETS PAID BACK GARCIA FEE
UPON SUCCESSFUL MOVING IT. IN A
SENIOR. OF COVER NINETEEN
HALTING. IN PERSON VISITS OF
THESE RCF VI'S DURING THIS
THERE DURING THE SELECTION
PROCESS REFERRAL SOURCES ARE A
CRUCIAL RESOURCE FOR FAMILIES.
LOOKING TO PLACE THEIR LOVED
ONES OUTSIDE OF THEIR HOME WITH
A LACK OF SUFFICIENT
REGULATIONS IN PLACE ON
REFERRAL SOURCES THIS IS. THE
TIME TO CODIFY FRAMEWORK IN THE
INTERESTS OF FAMILIES AB TWENTY
NINE TWENTY SIX BEGINS BY
CODIFYING GENERAL COMMON SENSE
REGULATIONS FOR ALL REFERRAL
SUCH AS- THE REQUIREMENT THAT
REFERRALS CAN ONLY BE MADE. TO
LICENSE RCF VI'S INTO RCMP
SECOND PROPERLY MEET A SENIOR
SPECIFIC NEEDS. PROHIBITING THE
REFERRAL TO AN RCMP IN WHICH
THE REFERRAL SOURCE HAS A
FINANCIAL INTEREST. UNLESS THE
SENIOR OR THEIR REPRESENTATIVES
SIGNED WAIVER. AN ALPINE. LIST
INSTEAD THAT IF THIS IS
OCCURRING OUR CFO RISPERDAL
SOURCE. REPORT PART OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. BECAUSE. FOR ALL
RCMP'S. THE SCOPE OF THEIR JOBS
AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY SIX ADDS
A SECOND BUT FAIR LAYER OF
REGULATIONS ON FINANCIAL COP
FINANCIALLY COMPENSATE REFERRAL
SOURCES. NOTABLY THIS BILL
REQUIRES A SET OF DISCLOSURES
BE GIVEN TO CLIENTS BEFORE
COMPENSATE REFERRAL. THESE
DISCLOSURES HAVE THE CONSUMER
IN MIND AMONG THEM A STATEMENT
ON WHETHER AND UNDER WHAT
CIRCUMSTANCES THE REFERRAL
SOURCE GETS PAID. WHICH
INCREASES TRANSPARENCY THIS
BILL COMES WITH NO COST TO THE
STATE AND HAS BEEN CRAFTED WITH
THE INPUT OF INDUSTRY LEADERS
CONSUMER ADVOCATES. I BELIEVE
IT IS OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
ENSURE THE WELL BEING OF OUR
SENIORS AND THIS BILL SEEKS TO
SIX INCH THAT'S THAT. MY YOU I
RESPECTFULLY ASK I'VE IN ON THE
PHONE TO TESTIFY FOR TODAY IS
CLIFF BURKE FROM A PLACE FOR
MOM AND MONICA MILLER FROM THE
CONSUMER ADVOCATES FOUR RCMP
REFORM. THANK YOU. WE WILL NOW
OPEN IT UP TO WITNESSES IN
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING LENGTH OF
HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEAN
RECALLS WILL INSTITUTE I'M
LIMITS ON TESTIMONY ACCORDINGLY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT POSITION
WILL BE LIMITED TO A TOTAL OF
THREE IT'S ALL OF THAT CAN TO
TESTIFIED REPUBLIC MUST LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THE NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MATTERS. MODERATOR CAN A UP THE
LINES FORTY. THOSE THAT ARE
FIVE. RELATED IN GERMAN ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME MODERATOR
JUST TO CLARIFY THIS IS
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT. WITH
BURKE. AND MONICA MILLER CAN
YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINE ONE
AT A TIME. ONE LAWMAKERS.
COOPER YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO
AHEAD. JUST ONE MOMENT PLEASE
WE'RE. EXPERIENCING SOME
DIFFICULTY ONCE ACCOMPLISHED.
WITNESS THEY ALREADY CALLED ME
OKAY THERE THERE YOU GO MR
BERGER LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR CLOSE
BERGEN BEHALF OF A PLACE FOR
MOM WHICH IS THE NATION'S
LEADING INTERNET REFERRAL
AGENCY WE'VE BEEN PLEASED TO
WORK THROUGHOUT THE COURSE OF
THIS YEAR WITH CONSUMER AB AND
OTHER STATES IN INDUSTRY
INCLUDING CARING DOT COM
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST THAT
REFERRAL AGENCIES TO CRAFT A
BILL THAT WOULD PROVIDE
CONSUMERS WITH A TRANSPARENT
PROCESS SURE CALIFORNIA. RIGHT
ASIAN. YOU MAY AN INFORMED
DECISION AS THE PINE THE RIGHT
FOR FAMILY MEMBERS- IS ALWAYS A
DIFFICULT SITUATION WHEN FAMILY
MEMBERS ARE FACED WITH TRYING
TO FIND A FACILITY QUITE OFTEN
ON SHORT NOTICE FOR A FAMILY
MEMBER- COOPER NINETEEN HIS DO
THAT ALL THE MORE OF A
DIFFICULT SITUATION THIS BILL
ISN'T DUE TO PROVIDE BEST
PRACTICES FOR DISCLOSURES AND
CONSUMER ACTIONS. BY PROVIDING.
CLOSE TO PRIOR TO. AS WELL AS
AN ACTING STATUTORY. FOR BASIC
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS IN THIS
AREA SUCH AS LIABILITY
INSURANCE- REQUIREMENTS DISPLAY
PRIVACY POLICY ON AN INTERNET
WEBSITE ENSURING THAT THERE WE
AVOID CONFLICTS OF INTEREST AND
REFERRALS. AS A PRODUCT OF
BETWEEN INDUSTRY AND CONSUMERS
WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT- FOR
ENACTING THIS KIND OF
PROTECTION AT THIS DIFFICULT
TIME AND APPRECIATE. THE HELP
THE HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE
STAFF ON THE- COMMITTEE. AFTER
IN RECENT BUYING WHICH IN THE
SENATE COMMITTEE TO ENSURE THAT
WE THE BEST POSSIBLE LANGUAGE
PROTECTION FOR CAN DRIVE UP.
NEXT WE'LL OPEN THE LINE OF
MONICA MILLER GO AHEAD PLEASE.
YES HELLO MONICA MILLER
REPRESENTING- CAR WHICH YOU
CONSUMER ADVOCATE FOR RCSD
REQUIREMENTS PERSON ONE THAT'S
ONE I THINK ON BOTH THE CHAIR
FOR STARTING THE BILL AS WELL
AS FOR STOCK COULD BE THAT A
LOT. AND WORKED VERY DILIGENTLY
WITH THAT VERY MUCH. MAKE SURE
THE BILL COULD BE IN THE
BACKSTOP POSSIBLE PLACE TO MOVE
FORWARD- AS YOU MAY KNOW THIS
IS A BILL THAT THEN PROCESS FOR
SEVERAL YEARS- ON THE GREAT
PLAINS BURKE CHIU INSURE THAT
CONSUMERS. ARE PROTECTED. PINE
TO. AS LIKE STILL. TRAINED BY
AGE THEIR LOVED ONE INTO THE
AND ARE NOT ABLE TOUR THEM ABLE
TO. TABLETS MUCH ACCESS AND TO
BILL PROVIDE THOSE PROTECTIONS
TO THE FAMILIES TO ENSURE THAT
THERE. IN THE PAST POSSIBLE HE
AND BEST CALL TO FILL CAN BE
THEIR NEEDS BECAUSE THEY ARE
HAVE TO NEEDS. DURING THE
APPRECIATE AGAIN YOUR TURN. THE
COMMITTEES TIME AND THE I'D- I
BEHALF OF KERR CONDUCT RESTREPO
A- THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU THIS MOMENT INVITE PUBLIC
PUBLIC COMEDY SUPPORT. OF A. B.
TWO NINE TWO SIX AND WILL BEGIN
WITH ROOM FORTY TWO ZERO THREE.
C. NONE WE WILL GO AHEAD AND
MOVE ON TO THE TELEPHONE LINE
BUTTERY PLEASE PUMP INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWO NINE TWO SIX AND
PROVIDE THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. TAKE CARE OF YOUR
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
NINE OH SIX PLEASE PRESS. ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME BUT
EIGHTEEN T. SPECIALIST WILL
GIVE YOU INFORMATION. AND I
WILL CALL YOU NOT YOUR LINE
NUMBER OUT. IF YOU'RE USING A
SPEAKER PHONE PICK UP YOUR
HANDSET OR PRESS ARE CHECKED TO
MAKE SURE YOUR PHONE IS ON MUTE.
YOU MAY REMOVE YOURSELF FROM
THE QUEUE BY PER REPRESSING THE
ONE THEN ZERO COMMENT. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE GATHER
THE INFORMATION. WE WILL GO
ONLINE SEVENTY FIVE GO AHEAD
PLEASE ONE MOMENT. WE WILL OPEN
UP BY SEVENTY FIVE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS WINDOW ARMENT MAKING
ON BEHALF OF NATIONAL PLACEMENT
AND REFERRAL ALLIANCE- VIRGINIA
I VOTE FOR AB NINETY SIX THANK
YOU. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
IN Q. YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK
YOU ARM HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
THE SUPPORTERS WE WILL NOW
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS AND
HEAR FROM ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. AND WE WILL GO
AHEAD AND MOVE. TO PUBLIC
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION IN ROOM
FORTY TWO ZERO THREE. C. NINE-
WE WILL GO AHEAD AND MOVED TO
THE TELEPHONE LINE AND JUST AS
A REMINDER TO THOSE WHO ARE
WAITING ON THE PHONE PLEASE
LIMIT YOUR TESTIMONY TO NAME
AFFILIATION AND YOUR POSITION
ON THE BILL. MODERATOR PLEASE
CONTENT VIGILS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY NINE TWENTY SIX PLEASE
PROVIDE THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
PEABODY. ONE IN Q. LINE SIXTY
FOUR. BLIGHTED SIXTY FOUR
PLEASE GLORIA. CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES HELLO YES PLEASE. I
APOLOGIZE THEY QUEUED UP IN
SUPPORT BUT I WAS A CALL DURING
THAT GROUP IT'S RECTANGLE
REPRESENTING SIX BED
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITY FOR
THE ELDERLY SIX THAT THERE YOU
ARE. WE DID COMMITTEE AUTHOR
AND BEIJING SHOP FOR ABOUT THAT
PUTTING OUT A BILL THAT AT THE
END IS REALLY IN GREAT SHAPE
AND WE ARE STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU JUST FOR
CLARIFICATION- WE ARE TAKING
PUBLIC COMMENT. REGARDING THIS
BILL ARE AT TO ALL THOSE THAT
ARE NOT POSITION AND MODERATOR
PLEASE PUMP INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF AB.
TWENTY NINE TWENTY SIX. LOWS IN
OPPOSITION POLICE TO PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THOSE TIME ONLY BILLS
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE TO PRESS
ONE ZERO.
THERE ARE LEARNING TO
AT THE START. A MODERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE CHECK THE LINE ONCE
AGAIN TO BE SURE THAT WE HAVE
HEARD FROM ALL- OF THE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY NINE TWENTY SIX. ONCE
AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMAN ON
THE PHONE LINES IF YOU WERE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE TO PRESS THE
ONE FOLLOWED BY THE. ZERO ONE
ZERO IF YOU WERE IN OPPOSITION.
NOT HAVE QUEUED UP MAIL. THANK
YOU AT THIS MOMENT WE WILL. I
HAVEN'T SEEN THE ADDITIONAL.
COMMENTS ON OPPOSITION WE WILL
MOVE IT TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AND I HAVE A SENATOR
JACKSON. ON THE ON THE GO. YES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I WANT TO
THANK AND COMMEND THE AUTHOR
THIS IS AN AREA THAT FOR TOO
LONG HAS BEEN FAR TOO OPAQUE.
AND AS WE SEE CALIFORNIANS
AGING IN THE AGING POPULATION
GROWING GREATER AND THE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE- NURSING
HOME OKAY CONDITIONS THERE HAVE
BEEN. LAID FOR MORE BEAR IS THE
RESULT OF THE CALL THE CRISIS
THIS IS REALLY VERY VERY
IMPORTANT SO I WANT TO I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR. IN
PARTICULARLY FOR TAKING THOSE
LAST- THOSE LAST AMENDMENTS
WHICH REALLY DO HELP TO PROTECT
THE CONSUMER- THAT BEING SAID I
THINK THIS IS JUST START- AND
AT SOME POINT IN TIME- WE'VE
EVEN. MORE COMMITTED TO MAKING
SURE THAT THERE IS THAT KIND
OF. OPENNESS AND THAT. THERE IS
A GREATER RESPONSIVENESS TO THE
NEEDS OF THE CONSUMER IN THIS
SITUATION- ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I AM STRUCK BY IS THAT THE
RIGHT TO. PROSECUTE THESE
CLAIMS REST WITH THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY- I SUSPECT THAT
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS. ARE NOT
HAPPY THAT THEY'RE BEING GIVEN
ADDED RESPONSIBILITIES
PARTICULARLY IN AREAS THAT ARE
DOING THEIR NORMAL DAILY WORK-
IT'S MY HOPE THAT GOING FORWARD
WE RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
PROVIDING PRIVATE RIGHTS OF
ACTION SO THAT WE'RE NOT
LOOKING ALWAYS TO THE STATE AND
THE OF OUR TAX DOLLARS TO
PROTECT PEOPLE UP BUT THAT
BEING SAID I KNOW HOW DIFFICULT
THIS TASK WAS I KNOW THAT THIS
IS. A THE UP IN A HARD FOUGHT.
IN TWO OF YOU KNOW THAT THE
WHOLE CONCERT OF MAY SURE THAT
WHEN WE- ARE SEEKING TO PROVIDE
A SAFE AND SECURE PLACE FOR OUR
SENIORS WHO NEED THAT
ADDITIONAL CARE. THAT WE CAN
SEND THEM. INTO THESE
FACILITIES PUT THEM INTO THESE
FACILITIES WITH A STRONG
CONFIDENCE THAT THEY ARE GOING
TO BE WELL CARED FOR AND GET
THE KIND OF SUPPORT AND CARE
AND TREATMENT THAT THEY DESERVE
AND THAT THEY IN THEIR- IN
THEIR WAITING YEARS IN THEIR
GOLDEN YEARS ARE TIME. TO STOP.
AGAIN I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR INTO LOOK FORWARD TO.
SEEING HOW THIS INVOLVES AND
HOW CONSUMER PROTECTIONS AND
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISMS ARE
EXPANDED GOING FORWARD. AND
WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO MOVE THE
BILL. SIX CENTER PANTY OF A
QUESTION. ANY ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS ON. FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. HEAD OVER TO
MOVE IT. AS A MEMBER CALDERON
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE YET THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I OUT MY ENTIRE
CAREER I CAME AND I STARTED I
WORKED ON SENIOR ISSUES LONG
TERM CARE INSURANCE ISSUES ARE
VERY MUCH SAW THIS AS- A
MILLENNIAL ISSUE THIS ISN'T
JUST AN ISSUE THAT IMPACTS
SENIORS BUT IN IMPACTS
EVERYBODY THESE ARE THE PEOPLE.
THERE ARE FAMILY MEMBERS WE
CARE SO MUCH ABOUT THEM AND WE
ARE DEALING WITH UNPRECEDENTED
TIMES THAT HAVE IT THAT HAVE
THROWN ON PRESIDENTE CHALLENGES
AT US AND WE JUST NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT ARE SENIORS ARE
FAMILY MEMBERS OUR LOVED ONES
ARE GETTING. CARE AND
ATTENTION- AND THE SERVICES
THAT THEY ABSOLUTELY DESERVE
WHEN IT COMES TO BEING PUT IN
ME PERSONALLY SO I'M VERY PROUD
TO HAVE WORKED ON THESE ISSUES
MY ENTIRE CAREER IN THE
LEGISLATURE I'M PROUD TO WORK
ON THIS ISSUE AND AGAIN REALLY
WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE. THE COMMITTEE STAFF
AND OF THE ISSUE MANY FOR ALL
OF AND MAKING THIS BILL AND
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SO WE HAVE
A MOTION BY SENATOR JACKSON. ON
AB TWO NINE TWO SIX THAT MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
SECRETARY CAN PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. AB TWO NINE TWO SIX. BY
CALDERON. DO YOU PASS AS
AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. HER
TADO I. RICARDO I JONES. JONES
I BILL. BELL I JACKSON. ACTION
HI. JACKSON I PANNED BY FANS HI
MELINDA HI. MELENDEZ AYE AND
WIENER WIENER FIVE SEVEN ZERO.
THE VOTE WAS SEVEN ZERO AND THE
BILL IS OUT. CONNECT WITH.
MOVING ON. TO SANTA ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN AB. THREE ONE THREE
FOUR FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RADIUS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS
FILLED. PRESENT YOUR BILL
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. TO THEIR
PRESENT AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY
FOUR A BILL WHICH EXTENDS THE
REFUGEE CASH ASSISTANCE OR RCA
PROGRAM DURING THIS PRECARIOUS
TIME. IMAGINE FLEEING A WAR
ZONE IN ARRIVING IN A NEW
COUNTRY COMPLETELY ALONE WITH
NO FRIENDS NO FAMILY. THE NEED
TO LEARN A NEW LANGUAGE
NAVIGATE NEW JOB MARKET AND
SECURE A JOB ALL WHILE TRYING
TO STAY SAFE DURING THE COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. THIS IS NO
EASY FEAT AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY
FOUR WILL CODIFY A CALIFORNIA
MATCH TO THE FEDERAL RCA
PROGRAM. BY DOING SO THE STATE
WILL CEMENT CALIFORNIA'S
COMMITMENT TO RESETTLING. TO
HELP THEM TO SELF SUFFICIENCY
BY EXTENDING THE FEDERAL
PROGRAM OF EIGHT MONTHS TO AN
ADDITIONAL EIGHT MONTHS FOR A
TOTAL OF SIXTEEN MONTHS. WHEN
ASSISTED UPON RESETTLEMENT
FUGEES CAN MORE QUICKLY LEAD
LIVES OF SELF SUFFICIENCY
WITHIN CALIFORNIA. THEY THEN
TURNED AROUND AND PROVIDE
SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC AND
CULTURAL CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE
STATE INCLUDING SEVENTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN SPENDING
POWER IN CALIFORNIA ALONE. THIS
BILL HAS HAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND NO OPPOSITION HERE TO
TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF THE BILL
IS AMHERST SHE'D WITH COUNCIL
ON AMERICAN ISLAMIC RELATIONS
CARE. AND KEVIN I WAS LANYON
WITH THE COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA WELFARE RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS. THANK YOU KAREN
SENATORS AND ASSEMBLYMEMBER
COOPER- DURING THE BILL TODAY-
GRAMMAR SHE NEEDS WITH CARE
CALIFORNIA. YOU'RE RIGHT INTO
CORE AT THE TOP SPONSORS AB.
THIRTY ONE THIRTY FOUR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER NOTED- REFUGEE
THE FINING TALKING INCREASE
WINTER SHOULD THE SHOW THEY
RESETTLED HERE IN CALIFORNIA A
MINUTE. BECAUSE THE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC WHERE TO BECOMING
INCREASINGLY IMPOSSIBLE FOR
THEM TO IDENTIFY AND FUTURE JOB
BEFORE THERE ARE CA BENEFITS OR
OTHER- SOCIAL BENEFITS EVEN
RUNNING OUT AND THEY'RE UNABLE
TO SECURE. BASIC NEEDS. HELLO
REFUGEES A VERY LONG IN OUR
STATE. ACCORDING TO OUR DIDN'T
LOOKING TO DO TO GET BY AND TO
THE CONTRIBUTION THAT THERE ARE
NO READING READ AND GIVEN THE
I. CREDIT. THAT WHETHER HOW. WE
ARE GRAHAM WITH THE RICH CREE
BY THE PENTAGON YOU WITHIN ONE
HUNDRED PROGRAM WHICH IS IN
CHARGE DOWN THINKING.
CALIFORNIA MATH. WOULD NOT EVEN
IN THE- ONE THE CURRENT ALL
SENTENCE ORACLE. WHICH I FOR.
THE INTO MY RECORD YOU TO OUR
ABLE BODY ABOUT THE DEPEND. ON
LARGE LIVING ALONE. AND
COMPLETELY IN SO SOLITARY AT
THAT POINT I WAS. THE RESULT.
BECAUSE OF THIS REALITY WITH.
INTEREST AND I. THE YOU. BUT
THIS IS KEVIN AGREE YOU HEAR ME
YES WE CAN. OKAY THIRTY UNTIL
OUT THERE WITH COERCION
CALIFORNIA WELCOME RECOGNIZES.
VERY GRATEFUL TO THE AUTHOR BOB
HERTZBERG SO OFTEN THE BILL
NUMBER TWELVE COSPONSORED THE
BILL- BILL IN SPECIAL IMPORTANT
THE- ONE ALL OF THE SERVICES
THAT SPOKE TO HELP PEOPLE TO
BECOME SELF SUFFICIENT. HAVE
SHUT DOWN PEOPLE WOULD HAVE
EIGHT MONTHS. AFTER BOND THAT
BASICALLY ARE SORT OF ON THEIR
OWN AND IT'S VERY HARD FOR
PEOPLE WHO COME TO THE COUNTRY
WITHOUT EVEN KNOWING HE- RUSH
WHAT THE NAME MIGHT WHO. LEARN
AND COMPETING IN THE JOB MARKET.
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT THEIR
OWN STRONG URGE FIVE OR THANK
YOU MUCH. THANK YOU AT THIS
MOMENT WE INVITE THE- FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY ONE THIRTY FOUR WILL
BEGIN WITH A ROOM FORTY TWO
ZERO THREE. C. NONE WE WILL GO
AHEAD AND MOVE OVER TO THE
TELEPHONE A PUBLIC COMMENT
LINE. AND AS A REMINDER TO
THOSE WERE WAITING ON THE PHONE
PLEASE LIMIT YOUR TESTIMONY TO
NAME AFFILIATION IN YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL. MODERATOR
PLEASE PUMP INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY ONE THIRTY FOUR. AND
PLEASE PROVIDE US WITH THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE WAITING.
WE HAVE SIXTEEN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME FIRST QUESTION OR RESPONSE
WILL COME FROM LINE THIRTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR MARRIAGE
WITH THE LATINO COALITION FOR
HEALTHY CALIFORNIANS FROM
SUPPORT. NINE FIFTY NINE.
REBECCA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
FIVE EIGHTY NINE. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS MICHELLE DEAL ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NINE THIRTY. SHE WOULD BE
TRANSFERRED AT TI ARE YOU IN
SUPPORT. ONE NINETEEN NINETY
NINE ZERO. THE MARK LOWER THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT. HEY WE HAVE
ONE FROM LINE EIGHTY FOUR.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
KATHY SANDERLING WITH THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. AS A
REMINDER TO OUR PHONE
PARTICIPANTS IF YOU NEED TO
WEIGH IN ON THIS. SESSIONS
PLEASE TO PRESS THE ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE ZERO IF
YOU NEED TO WEAR. NO MORALIZING
Q. THANK YOU HAVEN'T HEARD FROM
ALL SUPPORTERS WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION TO
AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY FOUR I
WILL BEGIN WITH ROOM FORTY TWO
ZERO THREE. SCENE NINE OUT WE
WILL MOVE TO THE TELEPHONE
PUBLIC COMMENT LINE. AND JUST
AS A REMINDER TO THOSE WHO ARE
WAITING ON THE PHONE PLEASE
LIMIT YOUR TESTIMONY TO NAME
AFFILIATION IN YOUR POSITION ON
THE BILL MODERATOR PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF AB
THIRTY ONE THIRTY FOUR AND
PROVIDE THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFY. ALL
THOSE IN OPPOSITION PLEASED TO
PRESS THE ONE FOLLOWED BY THE
ZERO. ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION. ONCE AGAIN FIVE
FALL PARTICIPANTS IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION POLICE TO PRESS THE
ONE FOLLOWED BY THE ZERO ONE
ZERO IF YOU ARE NOT OPPOSITION.
AND THERE ARE NO LINES INTO AT
THIS TIME MA'AM. THANK YOU AT
THIS MOMENT- WE WILL GO AHEAD
AND MOVE TO ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
WE HAVE CENTER MELENDEZ. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- I JUST HAD A
QUICK QUESTION DO YOU HAPPEN TO
KNOW HOW MANY REFUGEES
RESETTLED IN CALIFORNIA THE
LAST TWELVE MONTHS PERHAPS-
MAIS THE- AMMERSEE DEATH- YOU
COULD. RESPOND TO THAT YES.
HELLO SO IN A LARGER POPULATION
OF REFUGEES- I'M NOT EXACTLY
SERRANO WITH JOKES THAT WOULD
BE CAPTURE THE GUEST PARTICULAR
PROGRAMS THAT YOU DO BETTER IF
BODIED ADULTS WITHOUT
DEPENDENTS. POPULATION WITH
COOKIE ABOUT. WHAT HUNDRED AND-
HELLO EVERYONE IT'S CAMILLA
YOU'VE GOT. DEPARTMENT OF
SERVICES IT. I'M SORRY COULD
YOU THAT NO AGAIN IT WAS HARD
TO TAKE. IT IS THE ESTIMATES
WERE ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
INDIVIDUALS. AND THAT'S THAT'S
NOT THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO
RESETTLED HERE WITHIN THE LAST
TWELVE MONTHS THAT'S THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE CURRENTLY
WORKING THE PROGRAM THAT I
UNDERSTAND THAT CORRECTLY.
RUBIO OR CERTIFIED WITHIN THE
PARK CORRECT. OKAY THAT THANK
YOU SO BUT WE DON'T HAVE A
NUMBER OF HOW. HAVE RESETTLED
IN LAST TWELVE MONTHS. IN TERMS
OF LARGER REFUGEE FAMILIES- NOW
I DO YOU KNOW HOW CLOSE NUMBER
OKAY THANK YOU. YES THIS IS
KEVIN ARE YOU GUYS HEAR ME. YES
WE CAN. OKAY I THINK IT WILL
WORK WITH GOVERNMENT HUNDRED TO
FOUR HUNDRED IT'S GONE DOWN
IMMENSELY. AND I THINK THE
HUNDRED MEMBER THE NUMBER ARE
ABSENT MONTHS. MANY PEOPLE GO
OFF SO DOES THE RIVER VERY FEW
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF PEOPLE
HOLDS WHERE STATE THEY STILL
MADE IT. NUMBER ONE FIFTY. SO
THE COMING YEAR IS BECAUSE AND
OF FOUR HUNDRED AND THOSE
NUMBERS HAVE BEEN DECLINING AS
EVERYBODY KNOWS THANK YOU. DO
WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
FOR FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
CENTER MILITANTS ARE YOU. OKAY
SENATOR JONES. THANK YOU ASSUME
REYES AVERAGE OF THREE CONCERNS
ARE JUST I THINK THE ANALYST
RESSAM MINOR IS- WE'RE GOING TO
BE THE ONLY STATE THAT
SUPPLEMENTS THE FEDERAL PROGRAM
THE FIRST DATE THE SECOND THING
IS- UNDERSTANDING IS ONE OF THE
REFUGEES ARE IN CALIFORNIA AND
SETTLED TO QUALIFY FOR CALFRESH
CAL WORKS AND THEN OTHER
SUPPLEMENTARY- BENEFITS- FOR
EXAMPLE IN MY DISTRICT- MANY
REFUSE AND SELLERS- AND ROLE IN
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE OF FOR
ENGLISH LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES
AND- IS LIKE THAT. AND THE WHY
IF THE- CALL LOS PROGRAMS WHY
DO WE NEED THIS PROGRAM SECOND
YOU KNOW WHAT THE CURRENT
BUDGET DEFICIT ARE YOU
CONCERNED THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
ADDING- BENEFITS AT THE STATE
WON'T KEEP ITS PROMISES ON SO
THOSE THREE THINGS ARE ONLY
STATE CAL WORKS AT THE DEATH.
ON THE FIRST PART CAL WOULD BE
THE FIRST TO CODIFY THIS THERE
ARE TWO OTHER STATES THAT HAVE
ALREADY IMPLEMENTED SIMILAR
BENEFITS BUT IT HAS NOT BEEN
CODIFIED. AND PERHAPS ONE OF
THE ITNESSES CAN SHARE WITH US
IT'S MICHIGAN AND ONE OF THE AT
ANOTHER STATE- THEY ARE
ELIGIBLE THEY ARE REFUGEES WHO
HAVE BEEN ADMITTED HERE
ILLEGALLY. AN ELIGIBLE FOR THE
BENEFITS. AND ADDS TO THE-
FINANCIAL ASPECT OF THIS WE
HAVE LOOKED AT A NUMBER OF WAYS
THAT WE CAN REDUCE THE COST.
ONE IS PUTTING A SUNSET ON IT
AND WE'VE HAD THOSE
DISCUSSIONS- IT SO THERE ARE
THINGS THAT WE ARE LOOKING OUT
SPECIFICALLY AND I KNOW THAT
SOUNDS PORTANTINO'S GOING TO.
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE ABLE TO
AFFORD THIS BEFORE IT PASSES
OUT OF HIS COMMITTEE. ONE OF.
CHILDRESS'S JAVON YEAH CAL
WORKS PROGRAM IS ONLY AVAILABLE
TO PEOPLE WHO HAVE CHILDREN OUR
CITY PROGRAM THE REFUGEE CASH
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM IS ONLY
AVAILABLE TO THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
SINGLE OR CHILDLESS COUPLES SO
THAT'S WHERE THE CAR WORK
PROGRAM BILLS WHERE KIDS STILL
GET TROUT WORKS. THIS BILL
DOESN'T EVEN ADDRESS THEM THANK
YOU. WHEN I THINK I'M JUST
TOGETHER POINT IF I MAY THE-
CARE- WITH IT IN RECOGNITION OF
THE LACK OF THE BENEFIT BUT-
YOU HAD MENTIONED IMPLICATE
THE- RCA WOULD BE CREATED FOR
THE- INDIVIDUAL ALLY. IN THE
CURRENT ECONOMY AND CONGESTION
AND BACK. THE NEED FOR AN
EXTRACTION OF THE. ONE THAT.
THANK YOU. TO DO WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS. CENTER
JOHN TERRY THE GOOD OKAY. OKAY
R. ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. IT IS WITH
THESE REFUGEES LIVELIHOOD IN
MIND BUT I URGE AN AYE VOTE. SO
FORGIVE ME FOR THIS BUT CENTER
A AT HANNAH BETH JACKSON HAS A
COMMENT TO MAKE AN ADD TO THE
BED TO THIS BILL. THANK YOU I
I'M SORRY I DIDN'T- I WASN'T
QUICK ENOUGH FROM THE TRIGGER
THERE SO TO SPEAK I JUST WANTED
TO OBSERVE THAT- THESE ARE
FOLKS THAT ARE HERE. LEGALLY
THEY'VE BEEN VETTED. I THEY
HAVE BEEN THEY HAVE LEFT THEIR
NATIVE COUNTRY- FOR A VARIETY
OF. REASONS USUALLY FOR BEING
FORCED TO FLEE- FREQUENTLY
LEAVING FAMILY BEHIND- THIS IS
A FEDERAL PROGRAM AND AS I
UNDERSTAND IT AND PERHAPS IN
YOUR CLOTHES ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
WOULD YOU ADDRESS THE FACT
THAT. THIS IS A FEDERAL PROGRAM
THAT PROVIDES EIGHT MONTHS AND
BUT UP BUT FOR COVERT NINETEEN
THIS EPIDEMIC OF THAT MANY
ARGUE COULD HAVE BEEN STOPPED
ABOUT. WHERE WERE WE TO THIS
POINT. BUT OTHER BUT FOR THAT
ARE YOU WOULD NOT BE ASKING FOR
THIS ADDITIONAL FUNDING. IS
BEING ASSESSED AND TREATED
BECAUSE OF THE- EXTREME
ECONOMIC UP PEOPLE WITH THIS
PANDEMIC HAS CREATED. TO ADD
ACCURATE MOVED TO COMMENT ON.
THAT IN YOUR CLOTHES THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIRMAN YES PLEASE
SENATOR HANNAH BETH JACKSON IS
ABSOLUTELY CORRECT THE EIGHT
MONTHS THAT ARE PROVIDED TO THE
REFUGEES TO HELP THEM FIND
EMPLOYMENT A BECAUSE OF THE
SITUATION WITH COVERT NINETEEN
IT IS MUCH MORE DIFFICULT TO
FIND EMPLOYMENT NOT EVERYONE IS
GOING TO NEED. SINCE THE DAYS
TIRE EIGHT MY- BUT CALIFORNIA'S
COMMITMENT TO REFUGEES HAS BEEN
CLEARED AND THIS WILL JUST
CODIFY THAT. OFFER OF
ASSISTANCE FOR AN ADDITIONAL
EIGHT MONTHS IN ADDITION TO THE
EIGHT MONTHS. BUT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DOES PROVIDE. AND I
RESPECTFULLY URGE PRIVATE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER AREAS.
DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON AB
THIRTY ONE THIRTY FOUR. I WILL
MOVE SAID SENATOR JACKSON AND
JACKSON THANK YOU SENATOR
JACKSON WITH EMOTION- AND THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS ON AB THREE ONE
THREE FOUR. SECRETARY CAN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB THREE
ONE THREE FOUR BY RAY IS DUE
PASSED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE HER
TADO. I PER TITLE I'D JONES
JONES NO BELL. BELL I JACKSON
JACKSON ALL RIGHT. JACKSON AYE
PAN. MELENDEZ. WIENER WIENER
AYE WE'VE GOT FORTY ONE BUT TWO
VOTES NOT NINE ANYA. THE BOW IS
FOR ONE AND WE WILL PLACES
BELONG CALL. THANK YOU MANAGER
MEMBERS THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
THE LAST BUT CERTAINLY NOT
LEAST IS AGENDA ITEM NUMBER ONE
AB EIGHT TO SIX ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO PLEASE COME ON UP AND
FEEL FREE TO PRESENT YOUR BILL
WHEN YOU ARE READY.
ME TO
PRESENT. AND THANK YOU FOR
COMITY ME HAN AIRPLANE FLIGHT I
AB TWO TWENTY SIX WILL PROVIDE
SIX MONTHS OF BRIDGES SYSTEMS
FOR ALL IN A LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS INCLUDING THOSE
WERE DOCUMENTED I CURRENTLY
OVER FIVE MILLION HI
CALIFORNIA'S UNEMPLOYED
STRUGGLE TO PAY RENT GROCERIES
ARE BASIC NECESSITIES I DO THE
PANDEMIC IN LOS ANGELES REGION
ALONE THE FOOD BANK ALONE HAS
SEEN OVER 80% INCREASE. CAN
ASSIST. THIS BILL WOULD PROVIDE
MUCH NEEDED NECESSARY- FOOD
ASSISTANCE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AND I WOULD HAVE TO WITNESSES
TODAY- ONE FROM CHILE ONE FROM
THE REGIONAL FOOD BANK. ARE
THEY MISTER. THANK YOU SANTIAGO
MISTER MODERATE IF YOU COULD
OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES FOR THE
TWO WITNESSES. IN SUPPORT
PLEASE. ARE YOU ONCE AGAIN
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO ONE ZERO
IF YOU ARE SUPPORT MR MURRAY
WERE LOOKING FOR THE PRIMARY
WITNESSES ON- AB EIGHT TWENTY
SIX. WE DON'T HAVE A JOB. THERE
ARE LOOKING FOR A DEREK AT.
DEAR MR CHURCH JERIT POLACK WAR
ANGELICA SALAS ANGELICA I WOULD
I'M BEING TOLD- AS WE LOST ON
THE LINE BUT DEREK IS STILL
AVAILABLE OR LOOKING FOR DEREK
POLKA. AND IF THEY'RE NOT
AVAILABLE MISTER CHAIR WE
PROCEED AS WELL THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. LET'S GIVE THE
MODERATOR MOMENTARILY LOOK AT
CAN YOU HEAR ME YEAH WE CAN
HEAR YOU MISSPOKE AHEAD. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING. AS THEY
STATED MY NAME IS DEREK POLKA
AND I AND- POLICY AND RESEARCH
MANAGER REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES REGIONAL FOOD BANK.
I'LL BE SPEAKING ON MY WORST
THING AS A GOOD BANK IN L. A.
COUNTY. BUT I'D LIKE TO
EMPHASIZE THAT BECAUSE
REPRESENT. WHAT IS HAPPENING
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND. THE
NEED FOR THE SPELL. IN L. A. K.
FOOD BANK HAS GOT FROM. THREE
HUNDRED. PEOPLE PER MONTH
PRECOOKED IT. TO NEARLY ONE
MILLION PEOPLE PER MONTH.
THAT'S FINE IN. L. A. COUNTY
RESIDENT. OUR REPORT FROM NORTH
WHAT WHEN YOU THINK. HOUSEHOLD
HOPEFULLY SURVEY FOUND 27%
OPTED INTO RIGHT NOW I CAN. AND
THAT NEARLY THREE MILLION
PEOPLE SO ONE THREE. IRAQ
PASSED THE SENATE FIND AT THEIR
ABOUT ONE MILLION UNDOCUMENTED
INDIVIDUALS NOW I COUNTY. VERY
LARGE PORTION OF L. A. COUNTY-
AND I THINK WE'VE MANAGED TO
INCREASE. THE SUPPLY OF FOOD TO
MEET THE NEW THE NEW DEMAND
HOWEVER AND THEN CHALLENGING TO
ADD YOU TO OUR DISTRIBUTION
PARTNERS NOT BEING ABLE HAVE
FAILED AND AS FAR. BONTA LED
RELY ON OLDER ADULT VOLUNTEERS
SURE- WE'VE SHIFTED TO LARGE
SCALE DRIVE YOUR DISTRIBUTIONS
SERVING FROM ONE THOUSAND TO
SEVEN THOUSAND HOUSEHOLD THAT
IT I AM. BIG JOB. WITH THIS IS
THAT AT LEAST THOSE WHO ARE
ABLE TO DRAW. AND THOSE WHO ARE
EITHER WORK OR WITH THEIR
CHILDREN TYPICAL. IN PARTICULAR
FOR UNDOCK. HELPFUL AND IN THE-
ARE OFTEN FRONTLINE CENTRAL
WORKERS FORGETTING KEPT PUT
MOST AT RISK OF EXPOSURE TO
COBIT AND ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
THE VIRUS. FOR THE CRITICAL
WORKING THERE ASKING THEIR
LIVES BETTER OTHER IN.
FORTUNATELY THERE ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE SERVICE INDUSTRY WHO
HAVE HAD REDUCTION AT OUR JOB
LOSS AND AS UNDOCUMENTED
INDIVIDUALS. THEY HAVE LITTLE
OPTIONS WHEN IT COMES TO PAYING
RENT ARE GETTING FOOD. COLOR
FOOD BANKS ARE. STEPPING IN AS
MUCH AS WE CAN. FOR THOSE NOT
ABLE TO WORK CHECK MINIMUM
WOMEN IN HAND AND HAVE BOTH
OVER IMMIGRANT HOW. WE HAVE A
RIGHT MARK ENDING SEPTEMBER. WE
HAVE TO GO CLOTHES MEAN THAT
SCHOOL MEALS THAT ARE TYPICALLY
CONSISTED MIL PER HOUSEHOLD.
MIGHT NOT BE AN OPTION FOR SOME
FAMILY. SH OTHER ECONOMY IS
GETTING WORSE STUDENT INACTION
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL MORE JOB.
LOSSES WILL INCREASE FOOD
INSECURITY THROUGHOUT LA COUNTY
AND THE STATE. AT THE FOOD BANK
WITH STABILIZE THE MEAT CAN
MEET THAT DEMAND IN OUR
pCOMMUNITY BUT AT THE TOP CRISIS
CONTINUES AND DEVELOPING TO A
LONG TERM ECONOMIC CRISIS. WE
WILL THIS LINE IT ONE WAY WE
COULD BE WE COULD DO THAT BY
INCREASING GOVERNMENT DISTANT
SH FIVE BATCH. WE URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL AS IT WILL
NOT ONLY IMPROVE THE FOOD.
AMONG THE MOST HORRIBLE IT
ECONOMIC IT SHOULD BE A TIME
WHEN WE ARE MOST. REGION.
ECONOMIC HELP. BOARD THANK.
THANK YOU TO ARE YOU HEAR ME.
YES ARE YOU. LOOKING UP PROVIDE
A COME. SORRY SIGNAL THE HAVE A
LOOK AT WHO WAS HAPPY OFF A
JUST OF THE DIRECTOR POLICY. WE
CHAIRED LAP YOU KNOW SEARCH FOR
THE LIKE SOME OF THEM CLICKING
IN THIS CRITICAL BELL I THINK
YOU CAN COME WE WERE I AM VERY
THEY ALSO HOW AND AFTER
FINISHED A COUPLE NINETEEN BOOK
ON THE NINETEENTH NOT THIS.
IMMIGRANTS AND COMEDIAN COLORS
I'M LIKELY TO STOP FROM HEALTH
CONDITION AND WORKING IN WHICH
JOBS CANNOT BE DONE FROM THE
HOMES THE RESULT ARE
COMMUNITIES I DISTRICT. BY B.
NINETEEN ALSO TO LOSSES
CONGRESS HAS ENACTED FOR THE
WEEK PACKAGES PROVIDING. TO
STATE AND LOCAL. SERVICE THAT
HOWEVER MANY HOLES PROPOSAL THE
MATTER. ANY GUY ANY ANY ALL
SIX. AS SPOUSES OF U. S.
CITIZENS WHO ARE ON DOCTOR.
ECONOMIC SECURE ACKERMAN
SPEAKING. IS MAKING FOR
INSECURITY ACCURATE I'M MORE IN
TIME. SB THAT ONE IN FOUR
ADULTS IN SOME WITHOUT STATUS
AND- REPORTED EXPERIENCE FOOD
INSECURITY AND THE- THIRTY
COMPARED SIX. PERCENT OF WITH
FAMILY MEMBERS ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS AND- AB EIGHT TWENTY.
PROVIDE A LEVEL OF NEED FOR IN.
THE CURRENT BAN THEM FROM HOME.
DISPOSITION IT'S ABOUT
ASSISTANCE I'VE BEEN WITH
ACTIVISTS WITH LIQUID FOR.
THANK YOU AT THIS MOMENT WILL
INVITE UP COM AND SO. OF AB
EIGHT TO SAY AND WILL WITH ROOM
FOR TWO ZERO THREE. SEEN WILL
MOVE OUT WILL MOVE OVER TO THE
PUBLIC COME LINE. AND AS A
BERMAN TO THOSE WERE WAITING ON
THE PHONE PLEASE LIMIT YOUR
TESTIMONY TO NAME AFFILIATION
IN YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL
MODERATOR PLEASE PUMP
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB. EIGHT TWENTY
SIX AND PROVIDE THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WAITING FOR.
OUR CURRENTLY AT- TWELVE FOLKS
IN LINE AT THIS TIME. AND ROLES
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE ZERO.
FIRST RESPONSE COMES FROM LINE
THIRTY LINE THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OKAY. NINE SIX ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. EACH MORNING
SOMETHING PRASADA CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS WE
ARE PROUD TO CO SPONSOR AB
TWENTY SIX CHIRLA AND
ENTHUSIASTICALLY SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF OUR FORTY TWO MEMBER
SHE SERVE EVERY COUNTY IN
CALIFORNIA I'M ALSO EXPECTING
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
HUNGER ACTION COALITION A MULTI
STAKEHOLDER COALITION OF DOZENS
OF ORGANIZATIONS DEDICATED
ENDING HUNGER. WHAT FIFTY NINE.
WHAT BECKY GONZALEZ NOW OKAY OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. NINETY THREE. THANK
YOU ON BEHALF OF ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY MAYOR ERICA STUDY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. EIGHTY NINE.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS WHO SHALL
GAIL ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER AND
SUPPORT. BY NINETY FIVE. JUSTIN
ROUTER ON BEHALF OF ROOTS AS
CHANGE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WHY NINE ZERO. BARTOLO WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER HAPPENING TO
POINT. BLIND NINETY SIX.
FRIENDSHIP WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE AND AGRICULTURE NETWORK
IN SUPPORT. WELL I NINETY SEVEN.
ORIGINALLY HAPPENED IS THAT THE
NEW POLLUTION ARE HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA ACT TWENTY ONE CAN
YOU WORK BRITISH. INITIATIVE.
ANGELELLI IN STRONG SUPPORT.
FIVE EIGHTY FOUR HI KATHY
SANDERLING WITH THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
OF THE COURT. IF THERE ARE ANY
ADDITIONAL RESPONSES PLEASE TO
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME IN
SUPPORT ALL THOSE WHO SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO YOU HAVE
NOT RESPONDED. THERE ARE NO
FURTHER QUESTIONS IN QUEUE WITH
THIS CAR. THANK YOU HAVING
HEARD FROM ALL THE SUPPORTERS
WILL NOW MOVE ON. TO ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION AND BE
WE BY AND BY PUBLIC AND UP. AND.
FORTY TWO OH THREE. SEEN NONE
WE WILL MOVE ON OVER TO THE
TELEPHONE PUBLIC LINE. IT JUST
AS A REMINDER TO THOSE WHO ARE
WAITING ON THE PHONE PLEASE
LIMIT YOUR TESTIMONY TO NAME
AFFILIATION IN YOUR POSITION ON
THE BILL MODERATOR PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHT
BE EIGHT TO SIX AND PROVIDE THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE. BUT NOW
WE HAVE TEN LINES IN Q. WE WILL
FIRST MOVE TO LINE. FIVE THIRTY
BUT PLACE. ONE OF THE FIRST.
HELLO WE'RE HAVING SOME
DIFFICULTY. HELLO OPEN UP ONE
THIRTY GO AHEAD. I DO APOLOGIZE
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. THE
MODERATOR OF BUT CAN YOU PLEASE
SPEAK UP. YES LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WERE SPEAKING
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME EVEN IF
YOU HAVE PREVIOUSLY QUEUD UP
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. IF YOU'RE SPEAKING
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
THIS TIME WE HAVE AN ONGOING
QUEUING UP. THANK YOU AT THIS
MOMENT WILL GO HEAD AND MOVED
TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SENATOR
PAN. SO I THINK USE SUMMER
SANTIAGO AND- I'M GLAD THAT
YOU'RE HERE TO PRESENT THE BILL
YOURSELF I DON'T THINK I COULD
MATCH ELOQUENCE. BECAUSE VERY
IMPORTANT BILL AND I WOULD LIKE
TO MOVE THE BILL. ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. CASE SEEN NONE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CENTER I WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE LIKE TO CORRECT-
CENTER PAM IF HE WOULD'VE
EXCEEDED THE ELOQUENCE.
DIVISION BUT NOT IN ALL
FAIRNESS LOOK I APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE ON TAKING A SERIOUS
AND- AND HELPING US WITH THIS
LOOK AT THE BILL'S WRITTEN FOR
ALL LOW INCOME RESIDENTS STATED
CALIFORNIA WHO REQUIRE. ANY
ASSISTANCE AND FOOD WERE
SPECIFICALLY MAKING A CASE FOR
FOLKS OR DOCUMENT BUT I
APPRECIATED THE COMMITTEE'S
ABILITY TO PRESENT THIS AND
I'LL HOPEFULLY EARN A YES VOTE.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A PROMOTION
BY SENATOR PAN OF TO PASS TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS ON AB
EIGHT TO SIX. SECRETARY CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB EIGHT
TO SIX. BY SANTIAGO THE MOTION
IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS HER TADO. FIVE
FOR TARO ICE JONES. JONES NO
BELL. BELL BY JACKSON. JACKSON
I. JACKSON AYE PAN RIGHT HAND I
MELINDA'S SO MELENDEZ NO WINNER
OR WINNERS I THAT'S FIVE TWO.
THE BILL IS FIVE TWO AND THE
BILL IS OUT- I DO WANT TO TAKE
A QUICK MOMENT TO- HANDED OVER
TO OUR VICE CHAIR HE WANTED TO
BREAK A COUPLE OF COMMENTS.
WELL I WANTED TO I THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIRWOMAN- JIM JUST
LAUGHED- CENTER BELL SO
HOPEFULLY HIS STAFF'S STILL
LISTENING IN MAKING SURE MY
COMMENTS WITH THEM AND I'LL
MAKE SURE THE- FANS AS WELL I
JUST WANT TO A- AND DINNER BELL
WHO I'VE- THE OPPORTUNITY. NOW
TO SERVE WITH HER TENURE. I
WANT TO REGIONALLY PUT ON THE
HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE IN THE
ASSEMBLY. I WASN'T VERY HAPPY
ABOUT IT. BECAUSE IT WASN'T ONE
OF MY HOT BUTTON IS. AND IT
WASN'T REAL SOMETHING THAT I
WANTED TO DIG INTO AND WORK ON.
BUT BECAUSE OF HIS- PRESENCE AS
THE CHAIR AT THE- IN REACH OUT
TO. HE REALLY HELPED US OFF
SOME MY ROUGH EDGES. GOT HERE
THE ASSEMBLY. AND I JUST WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE IS HIS PASSION
AND COMPASSION. BERMAN HEALTH
ISSUES IN DEVELOP DESERVE
ADULTS DEVELOP JUST. AND THE
OTHER ISSUES THAT I HE AND I
AND I HAVE HAD THE OPTION TO
WORK ON AND- I APPRECIATED HIS
PROFESSIONALISM. AND REALLY
HIS- OUTLOOK AND- TAKE ON
SOLVING PROBLEMS AND
NONPARTISAN ISSUE. AND REACHING
OUT TO EVERYBODY- TO TRY TO
SOLVE. CHALLENGES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE AND I JUST WANTED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT AND YOU KNOW
IF I WAS GOVERNOR I WOULD
CERTAINLY ASK HIM TO BE THE
SECRETARY OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES BECAUSE I THINK. HE
WOULD DO A GREAT JOB IN THAT
POSITION AND- THE STATE
LEGISLATURE NEXT YEAR WILL HAVE
A GAP- THAT'LL BE HARD TO FILL.
IN I WON'T BE HERE AND I WILL
TRULY MISS HIM AND HIS- PASSION
AND COMPASSION IN THIS COMEDIAN
IN IN THIS HOUSE SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU PRICE CHAIRED BONTA
ECHOED COMMENTS. MADE BY A
BYSTRICA DAY CENTRE BELL I MEAN
I'VE BEEN HERE JUST A SHORT
AMOUNT OF TIME BUT HE'S BEEN A
GREAT MENTOR A GREAT COLLEAGUE
AND A GREAT FRIEND- HE'S GOING
TO BE SIGNIFICANTLY MISSED HERE
ON THE DIETS BUT I KNOW THAT.
HE'LL STILL BE AROUND AT VISINE
AND PROVIDING FEEDBACK TO US
ALSO ON THAT AND I KNOW THAT
THAT HE'LL CONTINUE TO DO THE-
THE PEOPLE'S WORK. I I. E. ALSO
WANT TO THANK OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND THE VICE CHAIR FOR.
ADJUSTED WORKING TOGETHER ON
YOU KNOW ALL THAT LEGISLATION
AND ESPECIALLY NOW TO THE TIME
DURING CO BED THANK YOU SO MUCH
YOUR ON THIS ON THIS COMMITTEE
AND I ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU DON'T LEAVE TILL WE
FINISH UP ALL OUR VOTES BUT WE
HAVE TO DO WE HAVE TO WHITE
THAT ARE ON THE CALL AND I
WANNA GO AHEAD AND MAKE SURE
THAT WE WILL. ON THESE BEFORE
WE LEAVES. AT THIS MOMENT WILL
TAKE UP A GENDER ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHT SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. AB AB TWO THREE EIGHT
SEVEN BY GRAYSON THE MOTION IS
DUE PASS AS AMENDED TO SENATE
FLOOR MELINDA'S. MELENDEZ I.
THE HAS SEVEN ZERO ABOUT A
SEVEN ZERO AND THAT BILL IS OUT.
ELEVEN AND THEN UP NEXT IS
AGENDA ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AB THREE ONE THREE FOUR BY RAY
IS THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
PAN PAN I MELENDEZ. WE'VE GOT
OF FIVE TO ONE. SO THE VOTE IS
FIVE ONE AND THAT BILL IS OUT.
NOPE THAT'S IT. AND BATCH OF.
YOU WANT TO ADD. WE WILL BE
TAKING UP CAN WE JUST.
FOR IT
KEEPS THE SENATE HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE WILL BE TAKEN UP AT
TWO MINUTES AT RECESS.
OKAY WE
ARE GOING TO RECONVENE AT THIS
MOMENT. THANK YOU TO ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
WERE ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE
OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US I WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS. THANK
YOU WE HAVE YOUR PURCHASE OF
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR
PATIENCE AND YOUR COOPERATION
WE HAVE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA
THE SENATE HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE THE CHART.